stephen colbert insurrectionists
will face no criminal charges why
because no one told them they had to
leave so apparently entering into a
building without approval is not
trespassing because no one told them to
leave it's funny i seem to recall
there's this beanie wearing podcaster
who pointed that out about the january
six protesters not the people riding in
the front of course but the people who
walked in when the doors were opened for
them and a certain other
progressive podcasting outlet got really
angry and called the beanie man stupid
congratulations the young turks to
getting this one so horribly wrong but
many people are pointing out the double
standard i'm not entirely sure it's a
it's a complete double standard the
people who worked for colbert and they
didn't all work for colbert for colbert
where some contractors entered into the
capitol building i think it actually it
was one of the build i think it was the
capital building and they were arrested
in charge for unlawful entry they're not
going to be prosecuted and it's because
no one told them they had to leave
that's how trespassing works there have
been
there's at least one case so far where a
guy has charges dismissed from january 6
because he proved not only that but the
cops waved him in so i actually think
this is really really good for the
january 6 defendants who are going to
point this out when it comes to their
trials so as much as people are
complaining with a double standard which
is fair
let's see
when they bring this up in court how
it's handled we also have another story
marjorie taylor green oh no oh boy
marjorie oh no
she tweeted something very offensive
about dr rachel levine
and twitter gave her a flag saying like
yeah you broke the rules but we're not
taking it down
and uh we'll talk about that because
it's it's a crazy topic nonetheless and
i understand why uh mtg is upset about
what's currently happening with dr
rachel levine advocating for child
gender affirmation surgeries so
naturally a lot of people are getting
heated on this we've got a bunch of
other stories joe biden's economic
policy uh has failed and his approval is
in the gutter well below like basically
all of the previous presidents and uh
this one's funny the young turks calling
joe rogan right wing media again because
joe
called
trump like a big baby or something and
it's just like
but we'll talk about it i guess
ladies and gentlemen before we get
started however head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com to pick up your
ageless multi-collagen secure your
supply of biotrusts ageless
multi-collagen 51 off at stronger bones
in life this is great for your joints
your skin your hair your nails it keeps
you looking young and healthy
if you go to bio trust stronger bone in
life bones and life dot com you'll get a
60 day money back guarantee the healthy
aging support of collagen in its ideal
forms five key types of collagen you
need from four different sources
hydrolyzed collagen peptides meaning
better and faster digestibility support
maximum benefits and for every order
today they will donate a nutritious meal
to a hungry child in your honor through
their partnership with no kid hungry.org
to date biotrust has provided over 5
million meals to hungry kids please help
biotrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year it is non-gmo and free
of artificial colors flavors
preservatives and sweetness and free of
gluten antibiotics and rbgh and rbs tea
nearly no odor or taste unlike bone
broth and other collagen supplements no
clumping unlike other supplements you'll
get free shipping with every order free
vip live health and fitness coaching
from biotrust's team of expert nutrition
and health coaches for life with every
order and i gotta say that right there
is like worth one order that's kind of
crazy they do that
and their free new e-report the 14 foods
for amazing skin with every order thank
you biotrust for sponsoring the show
strongerbonesandlife.com and ladies and
gentlemen we actually have a big
announcement wow i've been waiting to
make this announcement for months
huh
if you go to timcast.com
and click the members only or click on
the top right and sign up
when you sign up you will notice that we
are now officially using parallel
economy for all memberships and paypal
has been removed from the website we are
doing everything we can within reason to
avoid completely just breaking apart our
own systems while trying to get away
from silicon valley their psychotic
censorship and cult-like ideologies
parallel economy you may have seen
they've got a big old dan bongino on
their front page saying the ability to
run your business free from the
pressures of cancelled culture is
something i'm willing to fight for
freedom isn't going to protect itself
and parallel economy is committed to
fighting for a free fair and open
internet when you sign up right now at
timcast.com the payment processor we use
is parallel economy they they have
better rates they have guarantees about
censorship it is way better
and i've been very worried about paypal
now if you are a member on the website
and you use paypal nothing will change
you can still log in like normal
and that's grandfathered in
from this point forward the the
principal way people will be signing up
is using parallel economy which is also
loosely affiliated with rumble of course
we use the rumble player for uh all of
our posts
and uh you can also use stripe because
stripe also
there's there's other things that stripe
has brought up in terms of you know
trying trying to avoid censorship not
that they're the best
i'm really excited for this guys and i
really hope that you're willing to
support businesses that are taking uh
the risk and making the effort so let me
just say this when you sign up at
timcast.com not only are you going to
get access to our exclusive shows that
we're rolling out more we've got big
changes coming
tales from the inverted world ghost of
the civil war this is an hour-long
episode breaking down the story of shane
cashman going to georgia to find the
lost confederate gold this is the house
of seven ghosts part one it was an
expensive trip we're really excited for
it i think it's absolutely fantastic an
hour-long show as a member you'll get
access to the full season we're gonna
keep doing more and more things like
this and guess what
this is the start of something that i
hope becomes dominant and massive
we're using parallel economy to start a
streaming video service not unlike
netflix or hulu granted we are so much
smaller than they are but i'm hoping
that within five years we are competing
with them or beating them and the
payment processor is not a silicon
valley based woke company that takes
your money and uses it against you
so stop giving money to people who hate
you like like the daily wire says and
give it to companies that support you
and want to fight against the censorship
sign up at timcast.com using parallel
economy you are supporting us and your
supporting parallel economy i am so
excited for that announcement i have
been dying to make it for a long time
we've been working really really hard to
get it work to work and i assure you
there's going to be bugs probably yeah
because uh we
like we're not that big we're trying as
hard as we can but it's gonna be fun
this is this is the big news for us
right now i i assume parallel economy
will probably mention that you know
we're utilizing them for our membership
services now uh
you get a profile when you sign up shows
your account you've got your info in it
we're really excited we're really
grateful check out our shows tales from
the inverted world is exclusive for
members so if you like the ghost stories
if you want an hour-long chilling
suspenseful story
where shane is investigating lost
confederate gold bumping into ghosts and
ufos and someone even threatened to take
his life
check it out on the website and you're
also supporting parallel economy who is
supporting us
we got to do the work joining us today
oh and smash the like button of course
subscribe to the channel share the show
i got caught up in being really excited
about parallel economy it's super
awesome
joining us today with perfect timing
considering the comments from archery
taylor green is taylor silverman hi i'm
taylor silverman i'm a skateboarder and
i am
one of the new employees here at tim
cowell yeah yeah uh you've also been
doing a ton of speaking
about women's sports uh protecting
women's sports you you spoke in dc at a
big event what was that the our bodies
are sports valley yeah cool so uh it'll
be cool to talk to you about i mean it's
cool to hang out you talked about
everything for those that aren't
familiar taylor's been uh helping with
the vlog although we have special new
shows and other things planned with
taylor's help so we're really excited
for that and then uh yeah thanks for
hanging out taylor yeah thanks for
having me we got jamie hey everybody um
jamie kilstein i'm a stand-up comedian i
am writing the cast castle vlog which
there will be a huge announcement on
tomorrow youtube.com
castle we are doing
really big really exciting things you
guys will find out about that tomorrow
i'm doing stand up comedy in houston
august 5th and 6th i try not to curse on
the show it is very difficult i will
unload a hate speech i won't but i will
be very filthy august 5th and 6th you
can get tickets at the riot htx.com
that's in houston texas the riot htx dot
com i also have a big announcement maybe
not as big as tim's but close because of
the tim cast followers i have surpassed
on twitter
my pre-cancellation numbers i now have
uncanceled i am uncanceled i actually
now have more followers than i did
before i got canceled so if you would
like to be part of that you can go to
twitter.com jamiekillstein and i love
you all wait everybody doesn't get
fifteen thousand followers when they get
cancelled i guess no you gain followers
she gained followers i yeah i gotta you
know what i should have done when they
were like you cheated on your wife i
should have been like uh trans people
can't play sports with women and then i
would have gotten i wanna reverse
canceled yeah that would have been the
best i screwed up i'll stoke the flames
got to keep it hot strike when the iron
is smoking i also am here to play ian
crossland for me and crossland.net you
can catch me out there anytime hit me up
on social media let's get down to this
yes
i am so excited to have taylor on
tonight she and i were talking for the
show about some all sorts of issues we
talked about like an hour and a half
it's great she's gonna be a great guest
and i'm excited for tonight's show she
wanna say uh anomaly was actually
supposed to be on the show today but uh
i guess the airline the airport closed
so here's the deal the weather was
insane on the east coast he was supposed
to leave the airport at 2 20 p.m
he was texting us at like 5 p.m saying i
haven't left yet and i was like i don't
know if this is gonna work it was a
short flight but he was gonna continue
on hopefully we can rebuke him in the
future optimistic about that
yes and uh well let's jump into this
first story here we go ladies and
gentlemen from the daily mail stephen
colbert's the late show staff who were
arrested for unlawful entry to the
capitol last month will not be
prosecuted doj says they wouldn't have
been able to get convictions of those
including triumph the insult comic dog
now why is that
is it because uh they're in dc and dc
likes these people is that how it works
i would assume so but let's read see the
nine members of the late show staff
arrested for unlawfully entering the
capital last month will not be
prosecuted the doj has ruled the capitol
police released a statement monday night
in an update on the incident involving
members associated with stephen
colbert's talk show
they say the use attorney's office then
confirmed they would not be moving
forward the case because they wouldn't
have been able to secure convictions
according to a statement obtained by
axios
so let me just uh here we go they say
the united states capitol police have
been working with the u.s attorney's
office the district blah blah blah the
us uscp arrested nine people for
unlawful entry uh because members of the
group had been told several times before
they entered the congressional buildings
that they had to remain with the staff
escort inside the building and they
failed to do so the u.s capitol police
was just informed the u.s attorney's
office for the district of columbia is
declining to prosecute the case we
respect the decision the office has made
colbert dismissed the comparison between
the arrests and the january 6 right is a
non-serrection and joked triumph the
insult comic dog should be charged with
first degree puppetry hahaha no it's a
point it's a point about a double
standard he should be arrested for that
joke seriously i mean the show is just
not funny it used to be did you like it
like back in the day when he was doing
the oh just the o'reilly thing and a lot
of people didn't even know it was satire
i thought it was different and funny and
then it just slow
trump made comedy like comedians just
brains break essentially
and uh yeah
it's political punditry if you watch the
beginning of the show it's like a
political monologue almost at least the
last one i watched once i had to turn it
off yeah no i didn't have to i chose to
there you go you're old man finito i had
enough stephen colbert and his fake
smile like he's one of those people look
at pictures of me that he's smiling even
when you know like he's not necessarily
happy today he's just a joker it's that
kind of smile where you're like oh
you're hurting inside yeah what's going
on there
so so mike cernovich tweeted this when
you have absolute power you don't even
need to pretend even as people face
trial for walking into a building with
open doors dc democrats free their own
regime propagandists that is one way to
put it yeah but i think it's true they
would not have been able to secure a
conviction because you bring triumph the
insult comic dog actor into a courtroom
with with uh jurors from dc and they're
gonna be like but they're the good guys
they're allowed to break the law right
also i mean first of all if he was in
court my god i hope they would let him
like actually act using the puppet would
be amazing but
for the jury a demonstration of your of
your show okay here's the thing hey that
would be [ __ ] happy that would be
great
houston houston august where i can
actually say that and not feel bad um i
i mean i remember
so my last day job i was 22 i worked at
borders books and music in
columbus circle where i all pretty much
almost got fired every day i would hide
under the desk and drink cough syrup i
was a very sad
boy but cnn was right there and the one
time i hung out with robert smeigle who
does triumph it was me robert smeigle
and tucker carlson
just wait what just kicking it like no
you're joking no i swear to god it was
before the second george bush uh
election tucker wasn't like
known as wearing a bow tie yeah he was
though he
and he was just like ah bush is gonna
win but like he didn't seem thrilled
about it they were just hanging out they
were just like literally kicking it
drinking uh outside of of this borders
and
it was one of those moments where i'm
like
this whole thing is fake this is weird
it's all it's all fake like nobody
actually there's no one on the right who
seriously thinks that
colbert and triumph the insult comic
dogs should be arrested and then the
majority of people on the left not on
twitter
either they were sort of fed
complete fear propaganda about january
sex or they're just kind of indifferent
about it you know what i mean i mean
the the polls show most people actually
don't care they don't care they're like
what i mean i will say it is different
in the sense that
colbert funny or not is attempting
comedy was attempting satire just like
if we tried to do a bit on the white
house steps or whatever for for cass
castle um whereas january 6 was
politically motivated
both our first r1a issues so your right
to satirize insult and mock is the same
as your right to march to the to the
capital in protest the thing is
so i so look the people who ride it in
smashed windows obviously you charge
that that's that's that's that's that's
that's what you get on camera they're
being violent they're destroying things
you know that that pisses me off they
were like there was like a book book
stand by a window that someone smashed
into it's like bro that's like an
artifact of this country one of the like
if not the great like the greatest
nation on this planet in terms of
expansion of civil rights and and the
hard-fought battles we've had and you're
like just besmirching this awesome stuff
yeah but
the people who entered the building when
the doors were opened
did nothing that yeah they walked up one
guy had a cop waving him in and he
showed that to the judge and the judge
said okay dismiss that's insane you
can't charge someone for that the fact
that there are people still sitting in
jail or that that old lady that old lady
was not i look
for correct me if i'm wrong but that 69
year old cancer patient i'm pretty sure
wasn't smashing windows and fighting
with cops it could have been a russian
asset bro you don't know she was charged
with trespassing because people on the
other side of the building that didn't
see the riot
walked up to open doors there's a video
of police opening the door saying i
don't agree with it but i respect it and
those people are like yeah and they're
being let in right but the colbert
people get let go
yo we got serious trouble in this
country if there's two-tier legal system
you should definitely let that old lady
go i didn't know about that she was
probably just looking for her grandkids
or something who knows i mean
regardless it's like she's 69 and she
has cancer dude maybe over two months
she's probably two months yeah it's it's
really obvious the message they're
sending you know
this is why so many people just side
with the left on everything
refuse to speak up
because they know which way the machine
churns they know which way the valve is
going and if you just blindly march in
lockstep
you get you get leeway you get you get
free access but if you're some you know
doofy maga guy who sees the cop open the
doors and smile and wave you in and take
a selfie with you they're going to put
you in solitary
yeah this is really troubling to me
because i see this as the politicization
of our justice system which should upset
everyone and i know the left isn't going
to think this is a big deal until it
comes for them because they never tend
to but the fact of the matter is that
this will affect everyone and anyone
who's looking past what thomas soul
calls the first stage like stage one is
gonna realize that this is gonna turn
around and bite them really hard
somewhere down the road i gotta read
thomas soul uh you do i used to say this
when i
uh when i
got in a bit of trouble for talking
about drone strikes on conan when i was
like hey if i know we like obama i know
he makes cool spotify playlists i know
his wife seems awesome and he plays
basketball and they high-five and
fist-bump and she has a garden but also
if he is droning weddings and children
even if you like it when obama does it
because obama doesn't like a cool guy
way yeah uh you
who is gonna be the next president and
everyone was like it's fine and then it
was donald trump and it's like that's
why people need principles instead of
parties if you have principles these are
the principles i stand for then it
doesn't matter who's in power and in
fact you should be more upset when it's
your team
going against your morals because they
represent you so man shouldn't you speak
up that's why when it's like i hear cops
speak up against you know bad cops you
yeah man that's really important when
you hear liberals talk about how wolf
culture's gone crazy it's like yeah it's
like you know the people you get mad at
the most in your life are your family
and one it's most of our families are
insane but also it's because like we
love them they mean the most to us so
you're more emotionally invested i wish
people did that instead of just blindly
going on twitter and i used to do this
something controversial would happen and
i'd be like man i don't know about this
issue and then i'd see
how sort of my team lined up and i go
alright well i guess that's the tweet i
guess i gotta side with them or else i'm
gonna get in trouble that's the craziest
thing when the covington catholic thing
happened do you know about that the
coming catholic thing
so like you you're like being thrust
into politics and like you know
recently so there are these kids
standing on the on the steps of the
lincoln memorial minding their own
business when some dude gets in his face
banging the drum
someone snipped that video from like it
was like a really long live stream or
something wasn't it and then they put up
this clip making it seem like the kid
got in the face of the native american
it was like mocking him or something
and so i was getting inundated with
people who were like moderate
libertarian right-wing being like dude
tim did you see this this is messed up
like it's making us look bad and then i
was like what is it and they were like
bro this kid got in his face and i was
like really i where's the video like
it's right there i'm like that's just a
video of two people standing in front of
each other
but everyone just got in lockstep and
this is the problem with modern politics
but this is also why you will not be
criminally charged because not one of
these people is like i'm not going up
against the woke mob for this no you
like do you think the dc prosecutor is
like oh yeah i'll get reelected if i do
that sorry no no it's all political if
you get arrested like steve bannon right
now he just walked out of court recently
for the contempt charges
a dc jury
they don't care apparently i saw a
fractured man this one i just saw it and
there's a lot of preliminary work's
going to be done a juror apparently said
i don't care what he says i don't i
won't believe a word he says because of
who he affiliates with well that person
should be on a jury that's right but
this
look
when uh chauvin
was being was going to be tried in
minnesota
they tried to get a change of venue but
the judge said there is no venue in the
state where people don't know about this
case
my opinion then is case dismissed if you
can't have a fair trial you're done
right you could maybe ask for another
state to hold the trial where people
don't know but you can argue if
everybody is biased against you and you
can't have a fair trial you cannot be
tried you are free to go because it is
better that 10 guilty persons escaped
than one incent person suffer instead
they were just like no we have a sham
trial there's riots outside the jurors
are being brought in with armed police
officers carrying rifles and everybody
is terrified of the riots and the jurors
actually said they were scared of the
rights but uh seems fair to me
that's where we're gone
sheldon got the book thrown at him and
then two weeks ago i think they do five
life sentences or something stupid what
it was i don't know
some ridiculous i mean to be fair
he's a murderer like that was not good
and also set back like this again is
what i was talking about right it's like
you have something that blatant it's not
a black lives matter verse black lives
matter oh we're gonna get to our first
fight no i don't think i don't think you
watched any of the case i don't think
you uh
the video yeah i don't think you know
anything about it i just watched the
video there's multiple did you watch the
the full nine minute body camera footage
and did you listen to the police experts
no tim i'm trying to live a happy life i
just saw what twitter wanted me to see
and i saw the guy get killed and i was
like all right i'm done the show it was
when you learned the drugs that uh
what's george floyd was on he was on
five different drugs i think
he was fetting all he was behind the
wheel of a car high on fentanyl firstly
so he should have been arrested
immediately for that stuff meth
methamphetamines
marijuana why did you guys tell me that
before i wore my george floyd t-shirt on
the show tonight all the time come on
man he asked to be put on the ground
floyd did but shelvin did murder him he
did kill him i mean and as far as an
illegal killing so that's considered a
murder i mean every uh here's what i'm
basing it on uh because no i of course i
didn't know that stuff because i that
you probably had to dig to find that
stuff because it was so against the
mainstream i'm basing
what i'm talking about on the cops i've
talked to who were like livid and and in
the trial side interrupt no no no no no
no you're good but in the trial uh the
the state's
own witness argued that chauvin was
justified in using a higher degree of
force than he actually used
they actually had the continuum of force
shown in the trial and he said
because george floyd was on drugs not
you know like they don't know exactly
what he was doing but he was belligerent
yeah kicking on the chair and screaming
at that degree the state allowed the
police are allowed to use tasers
chauvin i don't believe pulled him out
of the v i'm not sure if he pulled him
out of the vehicle he asked to be pulled
out he was in the back that was before
and then they they pulled him out later
on the ground no i don't know if was
involved when chauvin arrived he was
kicking to get out of the vehicle and
the state that was prosecuting chauvin
said
yes he could have used a higher degree
of force but chose not to right then i
was like whoa you got reasonable doubt
on murder you have a cop who is who is
told by his training that he is allowed
to use a taser but said i'm going to do
less force than i'm actually allowed to
do
right there i'm like that's it he had no
intent to kill him well but he did less
force improperly and this is why there's
a picture no no in the training manual
of the police doing that exact maneuver
yeah no no no but what i'm saying is
improperly in the sense that and this is
from the cops i've talked to as well
they are trained horrifically one they
don't train enough two a lot of their
training is antiquated especially when
it comes to hand-to-hand combat while i
was listening to jocko talk about the
response of the uvaldi uh shooting and
he made a great point that i will quote
now everywhere uh i go whereas cops
should spend 20 of their time training
period training in firearms training in
tactical situations training in jiu
jitsu if you
i mean one a taser
probably wouldn't have killed him
whereas that improper choke would have
any blue belt you trained jiu jitsu for
a year two years you know how to put
someone who is on drugs the reason jiu
jitsu is great is because if someone's
on if he's all high on pcp and i break
someone's arm and stuff he may not feel
it all right hold on hold on so
for one
i think there was a probably justifiable
manslaughter charge in the duration of
the the the uh the restraint yes right
but that's about it the the issue is
do we tell this one officer who was
instructed to do everything he did that
he's gonna pay the price for the broken
system to appease a mob or do we change
the system instead of actually changing
anything all they did was lock this guy
and the other cops up and then tell all
the activists mission accomplished and
the activists went away well this is the
problem with so many issues is we just
try to duct tape solutions so people
move on to the next thing they're angry
about and we don't actually change the
system this happens with all the systems
that are broken where it's like i think
between that between the school
shootings we absolutely need to be
focusing on like getting cops better
training and it doesn't seem like that
means defunding them it means getting
them better training and letting them
train more instead of just you know sit
around
i i concur i agree
well to wrap it all back up the with the
point of the segment though just to make
the point no let's end on everyone
agreeing with it you're talking about
this
i was gonna say regardless of
um
like
what people believe about the case it's
really dangerous how many people pass a
judgment on it without watching the
trial yeah and without getting all the
evidence politics 101
we sit here on the show we pull up the
clips we watched written house we had
how many seven witnesses to the written
house case on this show
journalists people involved people who
are like i can only say a little bit
because i've been subpoenaed
and then from these interviews we were
like it's very clear kyle rittenhouse
was was innocent
but the did the media do any of that
it's remarkable that you've got people
who are like you know tim cast isn't
journalism what we do isn't journalism
and it's like well for one this show is
political commentary on journalism but
when we're sitting here with you
watching these videos showing you the
sources explaining why we think this
source is good
that's like
a million times better journalism than
say the new york times lying about you
know ukraine or something and trump well
and also we can ask questions that's why
i love being on this show where it's
like when you asked me if i saw that
video i was like nope
like this is what i saw and now that is
going to of course and it should
uh inform me whereas if i knew something
you guys didn't
you guys would do the same thing right
but look i i think one of the strongest
divisions between left and right of this
country is the left doesn't know
anything about the news and the right
does and that's really it it's
exemplified a million to one when i
point out ground dot news bias fact
check twitter blind spotter load up ben
shapiro like the most prominent
conservative orthodox jew and you'll
find him balanced between left and right
wing news you pull up the entire nbc
news team and it's all 100 left wing
that was me remember yeah so so this is
the issue with this country
is that
these people like washington post cnn
whoever else who smeared the covenant
catholic kids
yeah because they don't read they don't
watch they did zero investigation and
you know what i did i watched the
two-hour live stream someone was like
what happened i was like well i better
watch this two-hour live show on
facebook to see what it's all about and
i was like
so the black hebrew israelites were
there and the kids were heckling them
because they're racist anti-semites and
then this native american guy got up in
their faces and someone snipped that and
accused them i was like okay so i made a
video about it saying why is everybody
doing this even conservatives were like
they didn't read anything i was amazed
by that then you got aoc she fabricated
her january 6th story completely
fabricated it and i'm just like dude
look
there is a uh
the exception on the right
that prominent figures will put out fake
news it's the exception it happens i'll
call them out it is the rule on the left
almost everything they say is always
just misinformed
malformed nonsense well the bottom line
is if you truly believe in your
convictions if you truly believe in your
side if you truly believe in what you
are voting for then lying exaggerating
not letting the other side not even
addressing the other side
it's going to completely contradict what
you're trying to do it's just going to
turn people against you there's just two
cultures in this country and
we're seeing the emergence of there's an
article today i was reading about the
emergence of parallel economies
and uh i'll do this shout out too we'll
go we'll uh
several years ago i said the dangerous
thing about censorship with what's
happening on twitter facebook youtube is
that it will lead to
what's called a parallel economy we've
seen this pre-world war one
when people stop trading with each other
it creates distinct economic blocks that
can arm and develop resources
and then sustain a fight with each other
if there is one economic system
a sustained fight is not possible
because one group that gets excised from
it struggles to maintain any kind of
resources this is the goal of sanctions
we're going to cut you out of the global
financial payment system and then you
can't wage war against us although
that's failing because i would argue you
know joe biden but now we're actually
seeing it and the funny thing is about
the emergence of the parallel economy
we're a part of it
we are actively supporting the company
called parallel economy which we use
sign up at timcast.com and support
parallel economy but they literally call
themselves parallel economy that's art
imitates life and there will be a
multitude of parallel economies this is
not not the last but i don't i think it
might start uh you look you've got
getter parlor truth social
that's a sort of fracturing but
eventually
the quote unquote right will will will
have its singular space which may be
truth social
it will have its track its version of
silicon valley which is forming in
florida with rumble and parallel economy
i believe parallel economies in florida
i'm not entirely sure but you're gonna
have the emergence of a tech sector on
the east coast to compete against the
west coast tech sector and they're gonna
have two different kinds of rules and
then you look at truth social on the
left like we're not going there and the
right's going to be like twitter stupid
i got banned i don't want to be there
anyway and then you're going to have two
communication networks two financial
service networks you are going to have
states completely odds with each other
like you already do and then
well
and then you know i think the worst
conflict can come from having a
unipolar economy because people are more
like when you look at revolution all
these horrible bloody revolutions pretty
much
maybe not all of them but i'm saying the
revolts against monarchs not all of them
but a lot of the horrific stuff we've
seen in society is a revolt against a
monarch i guess you could say that two
parallel economies might come to blows
as well but i find like slave uprisings
are more dangerous and insidious because
people will blow up their own land
to get out and and i mean of course an
enemy will blow up your land as well
man maybe they're equally as dangerous
let's jump to this story and uh thanks
for watching crap that out there tim
axios.com reports
from axios twitter refuses to remove
marjorie taylor green's transphobic
tweets i have so much to say here we go
queen twitter on monday labeled but
refused to take down a pair of highly
transphobic tweets attacking admiral
rachel levine the assistant secretary of
health for the us department of health
and human services why it matters
twitter has a practice of often labeling
but not removing tweets from elected
officials that would otherwise violate
its terms of service the tweets linked
here misgender levine while also using
extremely vile terminology to describe
gender reassignment surgery
twitter's move means that people have to
click through a warning to view the
tweets twitter will also limit sharing
of the posts
what they're saying quote
the tweet you referenced violated the
twitter rules of unhateful conduct
twitter said a statement axios however
we've determined that it may be in the
public's interest for the tweets to
remain accessible and has been labeled
in line with our policies i just want to
pause real quick and say
if there is a barrier to seeing a
statement from a public official twitter
is engaged in politicking they are
engaged in providing special favors for
certain politicians and political
ideologies
that
has to be stopped okay
like imagine if during the civil rights
movement all the big companies were like
you're not allowed to advocate for these
things because they're unpopular so we
won't even cover them in the newspaper
or if we do people have to pay extra i
mean you need people to be able to talk
about ideas
glad
the lgbtq rights civil rights group
condemned the the move saying this
account has repeatedly intentionally
violated twitter's hateful conduct
guidelines against targeted dead naming
and misgendering of trans people a glad
spokesperson told axios it's clear that
some politicians see pushing malicious
anti-trans content on social media as
part of their election strategy even
with the full knowledge that such
content is violative um
i'll say this
jamie brought to the point before the
show
that marjorie taylor green uh do you
want to just say it i mean okay i'll set
this up so you can read
so you can read the tweet oh no we're
not going to read the tweet
oh we can't you guys have to okay you
guys have to read guys guys listen to me
everyone grab a drink and go read the
tweet because it is a masterpiece uh
this tweet is i mean i think both left
and the right would agree yes it is
taking something
that should be super simple that we
should all agree on um
do not give sex changes to children
that's it that's all you have to say
heard
she could have spent less time tweeting
if she just wrote don't give sex change
to children and then she could have gone
and hung out with her kids or done
whatever she did instead she was like
what if i write something completely
nuts and i'll have some rhymes in there
and i'll just and like i can't
she will make things that should be
simple
insane and in fact and and offensive
where it's like hey i don't like wearing
masks and she's like got it i'm gonna
bring up nazis and you're like no we
don't do that
over the top so i can understand the
anger hands down
admiral rachel levine made a video
advocating for affirmation of children
which means tran sex sex change
operations for children and medical
intervention and sterilization and
things like that
and marjorie taylor green naturally is
angry but marjorie taylor green uh look
you know we've had her on the show we'll
have her on the show uh again soon i i
think there's a lot so much about it
that's fantastic the way she challenges
congress
in this instance
and and and we'll talk about it because
something like alex stein is going to
happen again but i just feel like
the the righteous indignation wasn't
there instead it came out as like
unserious like silly
it's hard to take her seriously when she
takes stuff to like an offensive and
ridiculous place it's trumpian yeah it's
trumpian so i i gotta say this
you know
we're talking about it now
and maybe that's why we see a lot of
this if she came out and just said this
is wrong we wouldn't be saying anything
about the issue of giving sex change
operations to children coming from the
government
right advocacy coming from the
government and so you know look
i don't like the way she framed it
i'm glad the conversation is being put
in the forefront and there's a problem
in this country if that's how it has to
get done so let me make this point about
alex stein i criticized him for calling
aoc big booty latina and i'm like what
does that accomplish
and then it turns out a lot actually
because aoc then came out and called 1-6
effectively an inside job because of the
lack of security at the capitol and i
was like wow
that's like
really strange pretty cool but let me
just say like we got a problem
with i guess humanity
if you have to do things like this to
generate a conversation about screwed up
things because i was about to make the
exact point that you made
with stein where i was gonna be like who
is thinking i'm gonna let my kid
transition and then they jump on
facebook and they're like peen queen and
then suddenly they change their mind who
is that actually helping even us talking
about it we're not talking about
it we're not talking about child safety
right now we're talking about this dumb
tweet
but i also you know i i thought all the
trump stuff was wasn't gonna work and it
will and it worked i i feel like what
ends up happening with people like
marjorie taylor green or alex stein is
they take the brunt of the ire and then
a conversation is erupts around the
issue well and i think you nailed it
words like this the system is broken we
should be able to talk about it just
being like hey what's best for kids can
we have that conversation it shouldn't
be about you know
click bait tweets you know we we try to
have
i i'm just wondering if the time for
decorum is meaningless that the time to
for for
cordiality or uh collegial behavior is
just it's out well maybe she could at
least get a little more creative so that
her shock factor isn't at the expense of
others
because it's always offensive to one
group or another yeah but the issue here
is
one neither side cares at all about the
other side so why why is why are the
democrats doing a one-sided january 6
trial because they don't care to
convince republicans they want to rile
up democrats to get them to vote they
think we've locked it in there's no one
else to get
get them riled up
marjorie taylor green i'd assume i i'd
i'll ask her like why like what was your
thought behind this tweet like
walk us through your creative process
please well it's an unserious tweet like
i mean hands down you i'm sure a lot of
people thought it was funny i'm sure a
lot of people no one thought it was
funny that's not true she's got major
fans she's huge she raised more money
i'm pretty sure than like any other
member of congress what is happening
because because she does things like
this yeah and that's why trump was able
to do it too no that's yeah because
there are a lot of people who just
want the the symbols and the machine
behind what they oppose to be
struck down right so for antifa it's a
brick through a window does the brick
through the window actually change the
system right it doesn't even start a
conversation the only thing i'd say to
this is like i don't like the tweet but
she got people talking about it the the
the uh assistant secretary for the
health and human services is advocating
for child for children to get sex change
operations right okay well look fine
regular moderate individuals post
liberals disaffected liberals we can all
sit here and be like i don't like the
things she said it's like well who else
is calling out and standing up against
the government advocating for this kind
of stuff oh the worst part is going to
be when i meet her and i like her and
you will
that's the funny thing like i i told
jamie this before i was like jamie
you're gonna agree with everything she
says oh i hate it
i hate it so much we you guys won't tell
anybody right guys i can't lose the new
followers i got post cancellation come
on keep it between us
things like this obviously people are to
be like like
there's going to be a lot of people who
very much like what she said and she's
going to stand by what she said and be
like i'm allowed to say it and all that
stuff and she is and there's going to be
a lot of people
like us
former liberals or still traditional
liberals that have like aligned with the
moderates libertarians and right because
the work stuff's crazy and we're gonna
like you know kind of be like uh
she's right but like did she have to say
it that way right and in the end um
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
because there's nothing that's going to
get me to join the side of those giving
sex change operations to children
so
it doesn't matter
she can say whatever she wants
twitter can choose to ban her or not
her saying something that i might not
like and are saying something i agree
with but in a way i don't like won't
change the fact that the left already
hates her they're gonna keep hating her
the right likes her i just feel like
both sides have said
we've got everybody we can get let's
roll and if the left was intelligent at
all
they would
see
that even with that that that people
like us are aligning closer
with
ludicrous tweets like that then the
policies they're putting forward and
they would go hey maybe we need to back
up a little bit like maybe we're
screwing up if people are siding with
this
there's two distinct cultures in this
country
and there's no mending that divide
anymore there was a period where it was
one country split splitting down the
middle but we are well past that point
this is an example of it what's
happening in uh with dc with colbert is
an example of it
there's team a team b there's team red
there's team blue and if a team red
person walks into the courtroom and it's
in a team blue district they're gonna be
like i think there's
i don't identify with political teams
like people that are like my team's the
right republican red my team's the left
democratic blue i'm like i got a team if
i'm on a team it's not a politics team
i'm bored with politics i don't like
blabbit that just bot i'm on team like
science if there's like a you know
quantum science team that's you know my
except
except ian if if you were criminally
charged
in dc
they would just convict you
simply because you're on this i wouldn't
make assumptions you never know
and it depends on what it's for and what
i did what do you mean sometimes people
deserve to be convicted the colbert
people are being released the january
six people are not and it's the exact
same crime
in fact well it's the pole people were
warned not to be there and they were
there after hours too they knew they
were so it's worse but the other people
were involved in a violent no there were
no attack on the building well they were
there this is a big problem when
someone's a half a block away from a
crime that's going on are they
implicated in the thing going on a block
away they're not of course of course not
so
in this building those people on the
other side of the building should be
released in my opinion right but partly
why so at the very least there may be
people who get released but my point is
it's not hypothetical bro like we're
watching it literally happen the the
previous administration is arresting
former trump officials steve bannon just
left court today
like he is being criminally charged
because the democrats have forced people
to go in and testify and provide
statements that they're taking out of
context in a non-adversarial show trial
for january 6. they put me in their
january 6 evidence
and my dad texted me about that and was
like hey where are you working and i was
like please please wait till send him
the op-ed i did send him newsweek and
say
newsweek was so shocked to see me
included in the evidence that they asked
me to write an op-ed because they were
like they put the fence sitter milk
toast guy
in with the guys calling for a red
wedding the point is
raskin doesn't care dude is literally
like 15 minutes away from us by the way
and we have employees in his district
they don't care my point is you were at
a time now where you ian might be like i
don't want to be on anyone's team that's
okay they chose for you
is like plato said i'm not a i'm not i'm
not against these people that's the
difference if you go into a situation
being like you all are gonna convict me
i know it those people are gonna be like
yeah we're way more likely to do that
now but if you go in there saying i've
got an idea to help us all they're going
to be way less likely to convict you
that's
i think you're just it's just it's just
social dynamics you i don't know why you
think you're you're you know outside
of what they're all actually what's
actually happening it's like you you can
watch it happen we can see it happen you
can comment on it happening saying it's
wrong and then be like but it wouldn't
happen to me i don't get it i just want
to live in ian's world you see him he
seems so much happier that way it's a
resolution i was like ian what yeah like
i'm picturing ian in the courtroom like
brothers sisters come together can't we
all get along and it was like yeah
that's what i want i'm not even making
fun of you i'm legitimate
i'm talking about like pulling carbon
out of the atmosphere we can get lots of
questions the juror says your honor i
don't care what ian just said because of
who he affiliates with
like they did with steve bannon cringe
okay who's this juror that doesn't care
about the evidence that is in this can i
defend myself in this clown trial you've
created yes and right now
right now with steve and that's what's
happening what's going on with him what
so apparently and again i i saw a report
someone said a juror told the judge i
don't care what he should be extracted
from the courtroom yes exactly and the
point is in dc we are literally watching
people get released from committing a
crime in which they were warned not to
do it did it anyway and on january 6 a
69 year old cancer patient is going to
jail for two months
it is a two-tiered system i don't know
what she did i don't know the extent of
why fair point i don't either but she
was she was charged with trespassing
that would have been funny if like we're
defending her and she was just planting
explosions she's on the side yeah she's
the one that was waving them in yeah
um with the uh she's like i only have a
little bit to live let's take this place
down
i i don't know i i don't think that
people that have been trespassing right
now on capitol property should be
arrested at all i'm not playing double
standards here i'm not like well they
did it to them which was wrong so do it
to them which will still be wrong two
wrongs don't make a right what i'm
saying is in this situation you are
subject to the same system as everybody
else i understand that part right you
you you might say like i don't want to
be your team and i totally get it you're
right but you are whether you want to be
or not well and they will choose for i
mean we all have trial we have personal
tribes and friendships and communities
and stuff like that but it doesn't have
to be a political team i never believed
this and and i was you know but
tim made this point the last time i was
on the show and unfortunately it's like
from what i've seen on social media it's
like you're right which is the right is
far
much more accepting
right now to people with diverse views
than the left is and and i know that
because people on the left who have been
fans of mine
who when i started coming on this show
without listening would be like you're
out and then people on the right
who found me on this show will write me
and go hey man i don't agree with you
but like i'm glad you're on the show or
whatever and to me one of the reasons
that i was on the left that i loved
about it was we were supposedly the
party of inclusion right and now you are
far more likely like you're saying man
to be completely cut out whether it's in
the court of law whether it's on social
media even in like friendship groups i'm
hanging out with far more conservative
people who probably disagree with me on
a lot more than i would be with like a
lot of my old woke
i i am coming to believe for a variety
of reasons some private reasons
that the left and the right are being
divided among a
what's the uh um a propensity towards on
the right
morality like a sense of honor duty and
responsibility and the left is ignorance
or malice
and so i say tendency or propensity
towards the right has bad people
obviously the right has grifters the
right has all that but it's the
exception if you look at as i mentioned
with the bias checker you look at people
on the right you'll see they're fairly
balanced and trying to understand the
world you'll see that they're very much
about you know duty or family or
protecting or creating and then you look
at the life and it's very much about me
me mine i get i want
the picture of leah thomas on the podium
standing by themselves where the other
men are walking away like the entirety
of the event is saying to you
we do not like what you are doing right
here
but they don't care they say i'm happy
you have stories of these contests
skateboarding contests where no one will
clap or cheer for the biological male
competing against females
they don't care they laugh and they say
so what i get mine did you see that
recently leah thomas was nominated for
ncaa woman of the year award yeah
alongside riley gaines who was a swimmer
who spoke up about tying with her and
being pushed off the podium photo
it's shocking and someone from upenn
didn't get that opportunity at all
yeah well let's pull that story up
i feel so this is
let me pull this up from nbc i just i
feel sorry for all the girls who got
nominated because it's a huge honor to
even be nominated and to have it be made
a mockery of is so disrespectful
yeah here's the story from nbc news
trans swimmer leah thomas nominated for
ncaa woman of the year award the
university of pennsylvania athlete shot
to fame earlier this year when she
became the first transgender ncaa
champion in division history
now most of you know the story of leah
thomas i wonder i don't have the photo
here there's a photo where leah thomas
is standing on the podium and all the
girls go far away and take a picture
together leaving leah thomas the
transgender swimmer
to their their lonesome this to me is an
example of the
psychopathy the narcissism the
sociopathy just all of these like
i don't know i i you know look the point
i was just making for those that are
just tuning into this segment was that
the right has
let's let's look at jonathan heights
research the moral foundations there are
six the right has an equal balance of
all of them libertarians only have one
moral foundation it's hilarious it's a
liberty that's it they don't care about
anything else it's kind of creepy
actually if you look at the questions
asked and liberals have care and
fairness and nothing else
so it seems like you have a tendency
among the right conservatives to have a
balance to their to their views i wonder
if this has something to do with a a
tendency to live in rural areas
like in our experience what happens when
you catch a cute little animal that is a
rabies vector nobody wants to cause harm
to the cute little animal but when you
don't people die right and so you have
to make hard decisions and recognize hey
look you're hungry that chicken kill it
who's going to kill the chicken oh no
but we love the chickens they're so
funny you got you got to do it and i
wonder if that's the reason why people
growing up in cities isolated from all
of this have become narcissists to
become egotistical and have a have an
over overreaction towards the idea of
care and fairness
what i've been seeing
on the right you got your grifters you
got some people who are uh
notable for copyright infringement just
stealing contents pulling labels off it
and they've done well for themselves and
it pisses people off
but for the most part you have an
attempt at honesty conversation
compromise
and then you take a look at the left and
it's it's malicious it's ignorant yeah
it's angry
care and fairness is getting twisted i
think in the sense that if you see
someone suffering people are like oh i
want to make that suffering stop but in
reality
people sometimes need to suffer to grow
to learn about themselves they need to
go through pain and hardship and like
it's called tough love it's a very
specific thing and to eradicate that and
make sure that people are comfortable
frequently without resistance they're
gonna fall
i have to wonder about it though man
um my experience with even even today
the people on the right
that i'll talk to for instance sheamus
is a great example oh yeah seamus gets
mad when i when like when we argue about
abortion and i say like i think there
are circumstances where it's the
government should not be intervening and
sheamus freedom tunes good friend he's
very pro-life and thinks there should be
a nationwide ban on it and we disagree
and we've gotten heeded and then we
write jokes together and we laugh
together because you know we really do
just want to live together and and and
hope we can do right by each other and
then you know sheamus also knows you're
going to hell so he he wins the long
game well sheamus doesn't want me to go
down
he's trying to save us all no he is i
mean but he literally is yeah no i don't
know for his beliefs in his view that's
what he's trying to do and uh when we
argue about it we get angry but
afterwards we're laughing we're having
pizza
working together
but with the with the modern iteration
of whatever the left is the reason why
people like you jamie or you taylor are
now all of a sudden being associated
with the right for whatever reason is
because there's an open conversation on
the other side of those flames on the
left you're surrounded by a wall of fire
and they tell you if you go near you'll
be burned and that's why people are
scared to speak up and won't but on the
other side of it we're chilling
you know it's a it's this this is like
um it's like that movie the village you
ever see that that m night shyamalan
yeah
they're in the village they don't yeah
it's also like uh there's that breitbart
quote i have to bring up and then forget
the other side of the fire
well i don't know you want to pull it up
again
so uh you know andrew breitbart had a
quote about the fire and then someone
told me a different version of it but
i'll let and i always forget what the
quote was and then i asked him to look
it up
toward the fire quote let's see it walk
toward the fire don't worry about
what they call you all those things are
set against you because they want to
stop you in your tracks but if you keep
going you're sending a message that
people are rooting for you who are
agreeing with you the message is that
they can do it too
so i was talking you guys may be like
andrew breitbart too i know right what a
day for me you know he used to be a huge
liberal i do remember didn't he uh start
like huffington post with ariana yeah
yeah right so
someone would told me about that quote
and then what they said was think of it
like you're surrounded by a wall of fire
and everyone keeps saying if you go near
that you'll be burned don't go near that
and then eventually someone starts
walking towards it with all them
screaming stop you're crazy you're
stupid you're wrong don't do it they get
violent trying to stop you and then the
person jumps through the fire
and now they're on the other side and
what do they see it's a beach people are
hanging out with cool crisp air they're
drinking beers they're laughing they're
swimming
people are taking off to go home and
everyone else trapped inside is too
scared of what's on the other side or to
go near the flames the flames it's the
wokeness it's
if i speak up against this person the
woke people will attack me and destroy
me well some people get attacked and
destroyed regardless yeah and that's a
great
i'm laughing i'm laughing so hard
because
i mean even when the even the beach part
of the metaphor everyone was like you
can't for years you can't go on tim
pool's show you can't go on tim pool's
show then i show up here and you're like
we have swords and guitars and i'm like
this is amazing great this is so fun we
got drinks we got fancy whiskey
people of different political views oh i
burned my eyes on pappy's i never
thought that would happen right this
metaphor of the fire being wokeness is
is brilliant because if you get near it
and then you mock it it's gonna burn you
if you if you but if you pass through it
you're fine there's so much more outside
of this cult well and guys i have great
news i'm gonna i'm gonna do the ian i'm
gonna look straight to camera and say
this twitter isn't real yeah like
twitter isn't real the times where
you're getting mobbed or you're in an
argument you go outside birds are still
chirping man you go to starbucks person
the cashier will still talk to you you
can still have a normal conversation
with people you can still say hi you can
still pet strangers dogs like it is not
real and the majori i truly believe the
majority of people align with us where
they're decent people they want
everybody to have rights they're not
following the news they don't know they
don't know about what marjorie's writing
on facebook they just want to take care
of their family but the fire that's is
that's wokeness is moving it's burning
and and if you sit still if these people
outside the fire are fine but the fire
will move and surround them if they're
not aware of what's going on
i think you're half right i think that
my story is a really good example of
that because people were telling me from
the very start that i ruined my life and
i was never going to have a career and
that i should just like hurt myself and
leave skateboarding leave the internet
but
my life has only gotten better i've had
more opportunities i've gotten to
actually speak up about this issue
and have a bigger platform for it which
is important to me that's why i spoke up
in the first place so for those that
aren't familiar you compete in a
skateboarding contest against a
transgender biological male and came in
second
and now you're speaking at big events i
i don't want to make announcements for
you but you've been speaking it a lot
yeah i've been doing a lot and i'm
really grateful for that and i'm
grateful to work with a team of other
women who are either athletes who have
gone through a similar experience or
doctors or attorneys who support us
but
had i not just committed to what i said
and just gone through that fire like for
lack of a better term
than it would have just passed and there
was a second where you were just getting
burned right
for a moment before you tweeted before
colin writes colin wright tweeted
tweeted and then i saw it oh shout out
colin yeah thank you colin you're the
best he bought me hot chicken in
nashville this is oh yeah
i think i think it was his girlfriend
christina who showed him the story so
shout out to her too so let's let's
let's wrap this all together the analogy
is actually perfect
you were warned to stay away from the
fire even though it sucked where you
were and you were like this this is bad
it was worse just feeling like miserable
about not speaking up for myself but
then you heard me you walked to the fire
and the first thing that happened was
you got burned and people started just
crapping all over you well on the
internet not in real life no for sure
it's like the burn doesn't kill you it
hurts but then all of a sudden colin
wright grabbed your hand and pulled you
out of the fire on the other side colin
writes rad dude were were big fans whose
family shot several times and his
girlfriend i got to finally meet him in
person he was so cool well and actually
and i'll give props to you too taylor by
speaking up
what like i didn't i was so scared and
so filled with shame with mine that i
was just like i'm gonna disappear i i
literally still thought i was talking
about this with joe at a show like i
it was so culty where i was like by me
not defending myself still makes me a
better ally like i didn't want to say
anything that would make me sound like i
was trashing any women so i just stayed
quiet and because my only fans were
super woke people
everyone was just like they got their
marching orders and they bailed so i
didn't have
backup and then by me staying quiet
there was no one defending me you know
what i mean like
joe texted a couple people texted but
for the most part i just i went dark and
and just started teaching jitsu and so
when taylor did speak up for herself
like that does go to show
how powerful it can be when you really
believe what you
believe what you preach and also when
you just go no i'm not gonna take crap
and i'm gonna defend myself right away
there are people who will back you up
which is rad you know what like the best
piece of evidence that the right is not
a cult is that our good friends over at
patriots.win routinely call me cuck
in other words
but still but still routinely watch my
content and then insult me over it
fellow cultists can still call you a
cuck beware no they hate me
i don't know that's true the point is
they they smack talk me they smack talk
joe they're like these people are weak
but that right there shows they're
sharing content outside of their circle
right they're sharing things that other
people are saying explaining why they
think we're wrong and why that deserves
to be called a cuck or whatever and i
made a point i said this actually shows
they're not in a cult well because they
watch people they disagree with to learn
what they're saying the cult isolates
you from everyone else and ironically by
watching something that uh they
shouldn't be watching kind of makes them
a cuck
what do you think about the term
self-imposed
i refuse to accept that that wasn't
funny and i was like i will sit
[Laughter]
since then i mean yeah what happened
exactly without because it's somewhat of
a sensitive topic um
on youtube and things like that but you
were in a contest and then
it was someone that was a transgender
woman who was a biological man compete
in the contest and won first place
that's right i got second place and then
what what happened well i didn't speak
up about it right away because i didn't
know
how to handle it and i didn't want to
i want to just enjoy the contest and
skate like normal and i tried to just be
a good sport about it but
the more that i thought about it the
more i realized how unfair it was and
how wrong it was and i thought
i should reach out to red bull so i
emailed eric at red bull
and it was
it was a polite email i just said hey i
have some concerns about this being
unfair i'm not sure if you're the right
person to talk to about it but i'm sure
you can direct me to the right person
and we'd emailed before he'd always got
back to me it wasn't like i just like
emailed customer service and
and like hoped i would hear something
hope that's in one of the cars with a
big red bull can on top to pick you up
right no it was like the guy who was
organizing all the stuff for um the
contest after i had qualified in
michigan and
he just never responded
so
for a while i just tried to ignore it
and i had
shared the story of what had happened
with i'd say hundreds of skaters because
it had been like four or five months and
everybody was just like oh my gosh i'm
sorry that happened and
seeing everyone's reaction to it kind of
validated the way i was feeling
and i started to feel really guilty for
not speaking up because i had seen other
women speak up in other sports and i
knew this happened in skateboarding
more than just the one time it happened
to me it happened to me prior and i was
seeing it happen in other contests too
so
i felt guilty because i knew that being
in second place and there having been
money involved this is the type of story
people would listen to
and i did not expect it to blow up the
way that it did i thought it would cause
some local outrage and at least get a
conversation started since obviously
emailing red bull wasn't
a way to start a conversation about it
they did not want to have that
conversation at all
but um yeah it went viral and do you
think that um like moms
are like behind you
oh i get messages from parents all the
time there are so many parents who are
concerned about their kids and they have
young kids and they're concerned that
they're never going to get a fair
opportunity in sport or
might not even want to go try out for a
team if they're to face this
you think there's any value to having
like um elite a league where anyone can
compete men and women this is ridiculous
for me
no not an open league that's correct i i
don't think that's like a ridiculous
idea i think that in some sports perhaps
it could work
but i don't think that it should be at
the cost of the female division i think
it's important for there to be a female
division
so why why aren't more people speaking
out because they're scared because they
saw what happened to me on the internet
but what you got like a job and you're
traveling yeah hello people like the
people who hate comment on my page i
don't know them they don't affect my
life at all i've been traveling the
world i got a new job i'm skating
literally as part of my job thank you
tim we've got a bunch of skate projects
well so so full disclosure for people
listening you know we want to do a skate
shop we want to do contests we want to
do community events and i was just like
we need someone who's into that stuff to
like help make that happen so you know
taylor's gonna be working on a lot of
that stuff aside from just being in the
vlog or whatever yeah yeah yeah and
you've seen a game of skate is that i
i've beat him in a bunch of game escapes
but the thing is is he'll only allow a
camera and if he's already uh
yeah that's not true yeah so every time
you see it you gotta write about that
he'll like invite nick down as soon as
he's got me to t hold on
something i i never invited anybody
but i really want people to understand
that if you speak up about this
you will get support
there's a lot of people who support you
and there might be a bit of an attack on
the internet at first and depending on
where you live people in your community
might treat you like garbage but do you
want to like sit around pretending that
you agree with them or would you rather
stand up for what's right
it's really hard for me to sit around
and act like it was okay i never saw you
respond out of anger
to people i never saw you like demean
other people i've only heard you talk
about it in that how you feel about what
happened from the beginning i said i
don't want people to go attack anyone i
think that
the people who are responsible are the
contest organizers who allow it to
happen because the reality is all the
athletes competing are just going by the
rules
and i think that we just have to have an
honest conversation about
women deserving a fair space and what
can we do to create a solution that
everyone's happy with because what's
happening now is not fair and
there's a lot of people who are upset
about it i wouldn't my story wouldn't
have blown up if there weren't people
all over the world who are concerned
about what's going to happen to women's
sports if this continues well taylor
when you said you can sit around and
ignore it i was like oh that's what i
did like i remember when these
i would not consider myself by any means
transphobic or anti-trans in the
slightest and i would actually
i would tell people on the left who
don't want to speak up about these
issues that you really should speak up
about these issues because
when an issue on the left gets pushed so
far over the edge where we're talking
about surgery to kids where we're
talking about um women not being able to
compete in sports stuff like that right
by not talking about it what you're
essentially doing is you're taking the
most extreme version and now that's what
people think all trans people are right
all trans people are trying to you know
uh cut off your kids private parts and
then take your girls
gold medal and track and field or
whatever and
it's pushing more and more people to the
right because i remember
there would be stories about i think
when i was still doing a progressive
show is when fallon fox the transgender
mma fighter was just school schooling
women
schooling and i looked uh beating
beating the hell out of breaking their
skull
and i didn't want to cover it because i
i knew that i would get in trouble
but also
as like an mma fighter i was like i
don't think this is right and then i
would feel bad because i'm like but i'm
just uh i'm just a straight cis guy i
can't comment on it and we're just
creepy and yeah and we just want to talk
about it and i i didn't want to talk
about it yeah and
saying something that thought right
there that you would be like this seems
wrong but then divert you but i'm a
straight white man well yeah man i mean
when you're first of all
and we can catch we can get vulnerable
and not funny at all where one like i
have crippling depression and anxiety
and if i'm surrounded by i'm sure a lot
of people listening have felt this if
you're surrounded by people who will
belittle you because of those things
of course you're gonna think that it's
already a cult mentality
on top of me hating myself and having
imposter syndrome with whatever i do on
top of the fact that yeah i am kind of
like the enemy in that
terrain if someone just goes you're
speaking from privilege and my default
is to be down on myself anyway of course
i'm going to be like okay i guess i just
like shouldn't talk about it this is the
interesting thing here between the two
of you is that taylor
looked into the fire and just decided
one day to just jump through it they
grabbed you and threw you through it
they sure did
and then i was like we're gonna burn
them on the fire like wait it's not so
much of a fire as i thought it would
they thought they were putting you on
the fire you're like wait i can see
through it i don't feel like it was so
much a choice for me either because at a
certain point i felt like i had to do
something and i was really frustrated
i was escorted
what was the point this man through the
fireplace what was the moment when you
realized
i
well i don't know i think i felt
it's hard to say
because i had a lot of friends who are
very supportive of me including like
mentors who have
been around throughout the years of me
skateboarding and
i just felt like i needed to do the
right thing and i knew that people would
come after me i knew that people would
come after me for being jewish being in
israel but also being in israel i felt
really safe i knew that there wasn't
going to be an angry mob with pitchforks
outside of my house no one was going to
attack me at the skate park although i
did have the experience where the the
guy i was renting from the day after i
went on piers morgan he like asked me to
leave and i talked to him and i think it
was a misunderstanding plus there was a
language barrier
but um that was kind of scary i thought
for a second i messed my life up i'm
never going to be able to stay anywhere
but you communicated with him and
everything was fine yeah everything was
totally fine and we were cool after i
had someone throw me a skatepark yeah i
haven't had that happen at all in real
life i get threats online all day but
i'm sure it could happen
that's very poignant that you mentioned
that communication with the person that
had misunderstood something they saw you
in yeah but i actually i don't even know
if he saw me or if he was just like why
is this woman bringing a camera crew
into the place i'm renting to her i'm
not part of this
but everything was fine and i've been
i've gotten only support in real life
like it's been the opposite of getting
threatened at the skate park i like go
to a skate park in indiana and everyone
was high-fiving me excited i was there
well and what's really cool about shows
like this i think
is that
you know for a little while your only
option if you were thrown into the fire
by the left was to go full right wing
and that's what i refused to do even
when i was broke and in like a ratty
apartment infested with fleas like i did
not want to do that what's really cool
about spaces like this is it
you just feel safe you just feel safe to
figure out how you feel and to evolve
and to ask questions and it doesn't mean
suddenly okay now i'm all right oh that
didn't work okay now i'm now i'm a
bernie bro oh that didn't work okay i'll
be a centrist m um you don't have to do
that you all of us
listening should be allowed to evolve
opinions without being called a grifter
should be allowed to agree with a
conservative thing here a liberal thing
here a progressive thing here um without
having to like you were talking about
before ian subscribe to a team because
for the most part if you find a team you
line up with entirely on every single
issue you're probably lying is what i've
found let's uh let's jump to the story
from pink news
because i think we're going to see a lot
of people decide they don't want to be
associated with this group anymore in uh
what i would only describe as a
hilarious cell phone
pink news says anti-lgbtq
groomer slur banned on reddit in bid to
tackle hate speech your move twitter
okay let me just clarify uh
reddit did not ban the term groomer
but the fact that that's what they think
is happening and that the word groomer
itself is just describing the lgbtq
community is a ridiculous and hilarious
self-owned they're calling themselves
groomers when that's not what what's
being implied and the evidence for this
is that there's also a smear against a
group called gays against groomers
and it is lgbtq people who are like we
don't like what these these these these
groomers are doing in our name that
sounds good it's great that sounds very
because groomer as a word refers to
people who are grooming kids that's bad
well news is trying to conflate
the entirety of the lgbtq community with
the groomers
and it's likely because in my opinion
there are there have been there's been
an attempt among uh pedos to infiltrate
and get the community to defend them and
it's starting to work they tried
lgbt that didn't work they tried map
didn't work
groomer all of a sudden now
these activists are coming out and
defending groomers saying hey stop
making fun of us
and it's like us what uh
love is love thing is not real there's
erotic love and then there's storg which
is love of family there's lots of
different kinds of and there's
pedophilia which is not about loving but
using children that's totally a
different type of love according to the
greeks than like your love of family
okay so i'm trying to logically figure
out why the left would do this the only
thing i can think of is it because there
are bad faith people
who are homophobic who are just starting
to use the word groomer as sort of
a new way just to call all gay people
groomers and again i still disagree i
was trying to figure out why would you
do this why would you want to associate
yourself with the term groomer generally
no
uh there are probably some people who
have yes but in terms of what grimmer
actually refers to it's like libs of
tick tock pointing out teachers are
going after kids right they're referring
to people secretly meeting with children
and telling these things
there may be some people who are saying
that's a groomer and it's just a general
blanket idea but the idea behind groomer
is specific to the individual targeting
a child this is exactly
so let me just say
the rule that reddit implemented was on
one subreddit and it said don't refer to
all gay people as groomers that was the
actual rule pink news then comes out and
says they've completely banned the word
it begins to slur against gay people and
it's like not all groomers are evil like
for instance this very neutral take the
groom when people get married there's
the man is now the groom he's being
groomed by the woman to be a father
we're not talking about semantics
parents groom their children to become
young adults to become good people good
parents do but that's now when people
are grooming them to do evil that's a
that's the kind of grooming that you got
to watch out for ian is hashtag not all
groomers not all groomers except groomer
specifically is a verb that refers to a
specific concept in this lexicon i
understand yeah right so we don't we
don't need to describe the differences
between words like if i said you know
would you go for a run i'm not talking
about putting a floppy disk in a
computer i'm talking about going and
exercising and no one needs to
understand that argument
i did try to run with ian earlier but
keep it in mind
as the conversation evolves keep that
little tidbit in the back your mind well
and this is exactly what was killing me
about the
[Music]
you know the kid surgery when it comes
to trans rights where this is the same
thing it's like guys is this the hill we
want to die on because now
people on the right are just seeing lgbt
groups
defending the word groomer and they're
going to go all right i don't want to be
associated with that i want i want you
to imagine this
there's a skeevy creepy looking dude
yeah standing outside of a playground
looking at children and licking his lips
yep and you go hey
you get out of here you you pedo and
then a bunch of gay people walk over and
stand next to him and go stop making fun
of us right and you go wait what right
like
what what
well that's what pink news just did and
it's like uh my concern was with that
guy targeting the kids but not y'all
yeah i don't like the amalgamation of
groups like a pedophilia is nothing to
do with bisexuality no gay no
transgender transgenderism has nothing
to do with gay at
all you can be a straight person that
transitions your gender you don't have
to be
so this this weird grouping together
maybe it's out of like a survival
instinct or something isn't i think it's
doing more damage to them 100 percent
dude and how many gay people
were probably livid when they saw this
probably that's why there's a group
called gays against groomers yeah and
one also they probably don't want to
speak out because it's like oh now am i
going to get in trouble for for speaking
out against groomers well they don't
even want to get involved right it's not
working no like they they're they're
starting an organization look gays
against groomers
and the funny thing is they talk about
how there's like the lgb movement you
guys heard of this right yeah because so
there are people particularly in i think
the uk and they say
what does a woman liking a woman a man
liking a man or a man or woman liking
both have to do with being gender
dysphoric love it
so that's why there's been this lgb
movement that said that's totally
different from what we do get this a
transgender person who is a trans
lesbian that means they're biologically
male
transitioned to be a woman and then
marry a woman they do not need any
special laws made for them right they
could always in in 1990 those people
could have gotten married
gay people lesbians and bisexual people
had to actually get a legal right that's
why i understand fighting for you know
the gay marriage
t-q-i-a-s-2-p plus or whatever
don't
now in the instance a trans person was
biologically male and wanted to marry a
man because they were trans straight
they call it then you needed a special
law but that's only half
right or i shouldn't say half but that's
not the entirety of the trans community
in which case lgb all 100 of those
people needed
provisions to change in government so
they could get married the trans
community not completely queer community
not completely
ah intersex
nothing at all i mean the issue there is
there's a difference
and the cult
is trying to amalgamate as many groups
as possible like you ever see the image
of the muslim woman with the rainbow
hijab or whatever it's like a rainbow
flag behind her and i'm like
that's strange or there's a there was a
um
i don't know if it was the l word or
some show they had a a lesbian muslim
woman and it created huge outrage in the
muslim community around the world
because they were like this is not
acceptable they're trying to take as
many different groups and put them under
one umbrella even when they don't like
each other so i think it was in
birmingham in the uk
muslims came out to protest
the the schools doing an lgbt curriculum
and they were they were calling the
teachers like groomers and pedos and
stuff and saying we don't want our kids
learning this our kids are seven years
old they're too young for this and then
this guy goes i'm doing this for you i'm
doing this for you and they were like we
don't like you it's very strange when
they try and just lump everything
together so we put an m in there lgbt mq
muslims they put black people in the
flesh black and brown people i remember
when i was i remembered i was super woke
and there'd be a story like that whereas
like muslims are fighting with gay
people and i was like i don't know who's
side to take without getting in trouble
oh this is terrible
yeah what do i do you make fun of
yourself that's probably what that's
what comedians do i'm looking forward to
seeing the mca flag the muslim christian
atheist flag no it's the american
abrahamic alliance all-inclusive yeah
come on at some point you got to
represent yourself
forget about what color it is because
you're just a human and be your best and
and speak your mind here yeah
there are many gay people who don't like
groomers that's right there should be so
they shouldn't be controversial you
maniacs well so this is why i say when
someone comes out and says that groomer
is a slur against all lgbtq people
that's the pita walking up to the like
okay let's do another analogy yeah
there's a creepy pedo guy looking at
kids and look at his lips and you say
hey you peto you get away from those
kids and he walks over to a group of gay
people and goes that guy's making fun of
us right right and then they go hey
don't make fun of us
i think an even more realistic analogy
is like when a teacher starts talking to
kids about things that aren't
appropriate to discuss with kids and
telling them to keep it a secret from
their parents and then online
the woke folk defend it yeah it's messed
up because they're using the badge of
teacher to hide behind because if they
did it at a public park they'd get
arrested especially
especially they were licking their lips
like all of tim's pedos were in his
analogies yeah yeah i'm using like an
extreme example of like
about anything let me
just if you go to one of these schools
and take the book genderqueer off the
bookshelf and then walk up to a child
open it and read it you're going to
prison yeah i no weird guys when we were
growing up
maybe not you taylor but we just
probably feared our teachers we didn't
know anything for all i knew my english
teacher lived in a shack like they just
had these haunting backstories where you
would kind of hear rumors about like
maybe where they lived if you ever saw
them out in public you would just like
run in the other direction at no point
would my like grizzled shop teacher be
like so i was laying next to a man like
he would have been arrested he would
have been arrested
um i i don't know about you but we
didn't have a whole lot of respect for
our teachers
i feared them dude yeah i mean i wasn't
scared of my teachers but i didn't know
much about their personal lives right
right that's true too
the only the only thing i knew about one
teacher was that she got married because
her name changed oh yeah or like a
teacher gets pregnant obviously you're
gonna know that yeah and we were like
hey look you're just pregnant and then
she like stopped but she wasn't like you
want to know what position we did to
conceive you're like no no no
i'm 10 years old no
i'm so little the 10 year olds would go
what's a position just let me tell you
right no yeah let me draw it and then
don't tell your parents creepy dude yeah
do you think so
honestly your opinion do you think that
it is them being
legit groomer pedophile blah blah or do
you think some of them are just trying
to
show how progressive they are and make
like a thing about it no some are some
are groomers and some are trying to
indoctrinate kids because they know they
don't have any of their own but also
regardless of the intention it has the
same effect oh yeah no no no neither
answer was correct they're both very bad
to be clear i'm just curious about what
you guys thought the left doesn't have
kids they have yours
so because they're not having kids
they're sterilizing their kids and
they're aborting their kids this country
is 20 30 years away from being christian
conservative hardcore and it's really
crazy because
this country went from like you know
obviously you go way back in time it's
much more traditionalist for obvious
reasons it's back in time but there was
rampant racism literal slavery and a lot
and dowries and things like that and
then over time these things change and
there's there's there's there's progress
and liberalism obama
then there used to be even with the
first amendment you couldn't swear yeah
even with the first amendment you
couldn't say naughty words yeah you
couldn't wear certain clothes and then
we became very liberal but then we
became so liberal that
liberals started killing their own
children
went too far in one direction and that's
going to result in a flow back in the
other direction i don't think it's going
to get more conservative yeah i don't
think it's going to be christian though
because like what you're saying earlier
jamie about like you you got excised
from the left but you didn't want to go
full right like you just wouldn't let
yourself like people aren't just gonna
say okay now i believe that cult like
some people they will some people might
but people in reality don't want to be
in a cult well and what's what's so
insidious about people on the left is
they they have will and have
said that i already have that i'm
already a right-wing grifter and
whatever and you guys have actually had
conversations with me and it's like no
man i just ask questions and i'm friends
with people who don't
share my exact world view and i'm pretty
happy
i'll see like some people they're like
getting disenfranchised with reality and
you know when things can start to go
haywire like if you see the stand you
know people become religious then
they're like you know what
yeah now i believe in jesus and i'm like
wait hold on
this is like a lifelong
exploration you don't like get
traumatized and then all of a sudden now
you have a new religion you know so this
is actually interesting i pulled up the
stats and if you simplify the stats on
is the united states becoming more
christian they say no
because the country is 75 christian now
but by 2050 it'll be 63 percent and you
look at it it's actually a 20 million uh
individual increase so there will be a
massive increase in the number of
christians in this country however
there's going to be they say a larger
increase in non-christians there's going
to be about
90 or so million
new population of which only 20 million
are christians reducing the overall
percentage
where are those non-christians coming
from
if non-christians abort their kids well
we're seeing about a million people per
year coming from illegal immigration or
more so i wonder if that's the issue
however many people coming from latin
american countries are also christians
so i don't understand their numbers
my
my belief and i don't know if it answers
your question is that it's religion's
getting fun now that we can see cosmic
microwave background and radiation we're
like whoa is god actually quantifiable
like this is an opportunity for a
generation to have a non-organized just
a kind of a belief structure about the
essence of reality it is much more it is
much more fun to where the majority of
people who have found god at a later age
it's not that i've met it's not oh i
went to jail or oh i was raised going to
church it's like well i did dmt and
you're like yeah there it is man
i think there's a lot of secular people
too who have similar values as
christians in some ways without
believing all the religious stuff yeah
our country is based on on the tenets of
christianity so it's through most people
in the society we talk about this quite
a bit that um the atheists of the 90s
2000 2010s don't realize they completely
operate on a christian moral framework
but it's because
they don't know anything about
christianity they think that their
morality is inherent to them because
another issue they've probably never
traveled to other countries that don't
have those moral frameworks
yeah i mean i
kind of what taylor was saying you know
i know for me
i think there are a lot of people in my
generation especially that
you know you'd say
i'm spiritual but not religious right
and so they saw what happened with the
catholic church or they were raised
religious and they rebelled against
their parents but they never really let
go of spirituality or they never became
a full-fledged atheist and one of the
things that i always sort of secretly
admired about conservatives is
when you looked at their words about
what they stood for it was like family
values god hard work and i was like
why are we against those things that
sounds great like why was the left like
what were our words it was like weed
gentrification like it was just a bummer
right
and
now i think that because the left has
gone so far
uh cuckoo bananas i think that a lot of
people a lot of secular people who
you know ran out of richard dawkins
books to read i think a lot of people
are kind of craving that morality or
those family values that are
predominantly seen on the right or
within some kind of religious framework
i think that's normal too as you get
older
yeah is it because we're closer to death
and it's like hey just in case i'm wrong
i'm gonna start praying
i i think it um you know
dennis prager brought up a really great
point he says what does he call it cut
flower yeah caught flower culture
culture is what he called it that's what
he called it yeah so you have a flower
it's beautiful you cut it from its roots
and it stays beautiful but eventually
withers and dies
and that's
what i think is happening you had a
period where well i mean for a long time
this country was like 100 christian
basically right right and that had a lot
of bad things about it um you know
culturally there was a lot of uh is
rigid very rigid like you know george
carlin getting arrested for swearing and
stuff like that right
then eventually you get some atheism but
it's still based on moral values from
christians so they start saying things
like i don't think god's real
but i still agree the innocent should
not be prosecuted for crimes they may
not have committed unless it's proven
beyond a reasonable doubt
and then you're like where does that
come from and they don't know right
because they didn't study the bible and
they didn't learn about the history of
blackstone's formulation and where it
came from and all the stuff and then you
realize like hey wait a minute china
doesn't have that like in china they
just lock you up and they torture you if
you oppose the government now that's
communism you know that's not the
traditional chinese values but the point
is those people are not raised with the
same moral values we have
interesting
now we're starting to see what happens
when the atheist children of parents who
don't know where their values come from
raise children
and they don't know how to trait to
bring those values to those kids and
those kids are you know the current
millennial generation
well my parents did it right man where i
wasn't raised religious
my dad is a jew
and my mom is
christian-ish and we didn't go to church
and we didn't go to synagogue but we
celebrated passover and hanukkah and
christmas and you know they would always
tell us about our
our relatives and our ancestors and all
this stuff but they
believed in god and believed in the
framework of just being a good person
and so they didn't raise us
anti-religious you know what i mean like
we didn't go to church we didn't get
burnt out on that but it was still hey
be a good person we're not alone we
don't know but we're not alone and i
think that's why i never could go that
like full throttle hateful atheist who
just spends all day on you know reddit
calling religious people dumb i think
that's why i still always
sought out
something because you don't know you
can't be if you say you're an atheist
you you're just as
fundamentalist like
even when i thought i was an atheist i
called myself agnostic because i don't
know if i called myself an atheist and
god came crashing down to the ceiling
and was like i'm real i wouldn't be like
no i've read sam harris i'd be like all
right man i guess i was wrong which
makes me agnostic what's funny is
looking at these polls about the future
of christianity
i wonder how they make the determination
because you can't predict culture if you
could make your investments now you'll
be rich
i think they underestimate
the cultural shift
that dmt particularly will bring a bring
upon atheists it's possible for real
dude christianity is going to reform
into like because the idea of christ is
like the anointed one and jesus just
happened to be the christ of that time
he was anointed by god but we can all be
anointed by god i believe that anyway
that it's flowing through us all yeah
media well i mean i uh i made that dmt
thing as kind of a joke but am i allowed
to talk about uh me doing drugs on
youtube hell yeah well we talk about dmt
all the time we just don't have you're
not supposed to do drugs on youtube i
had a terrible experience where i found
god um i
no i i uh
my
during covid or right before lockdown
my
cat died and my girlfriend left in the
same week and it was awful and i was
infinitely more upset about the cat than
the girl because he was the best oh and
she would like see she would see me
crying and be like don't worry we'll
still be friends and i was like oh i'm
crying about the cat but i'd be like
yeah yeah we'll still be friends
and so over valentine's day it was my
first valentine's day i'd ever spent
alone i was like i'm gonna take
mushrooms for the first time since high
school and everyone was like that is the
worst idea i've ever heard
and they're like you're gonna be alone
on valentine's day and guess what i
wasn't alone i was with everyone and god
and i for the longest time i considered
myself agnostic i considered but
people have these experiences people on
their deathbed again when they are given
by medical professionals there are
doctors who do this
people on their deathbed who are so
scared of death
they are with a doctor with a
professional given psilocybin
and they no longer fear death they do
see something it does open something up
in you um what if like right before
people died we just blasted them with
dmt would be the best like like when you
they say when you die
your brain releases dmt right like a ton
of it what if they were just like
tenfold baby intravenous drip i'm
putting that in my will let's go yeah
we're all putting that in our wheels yo
i think you should i want that in my
employment contract here right i think
when you're like certifiably like about
to die you should be able to just like
yeah right to choose i think is that
what they call well look they're right
to try to try is like if you're dying
you can try a drug i'm saying no like if
the doctor's like you got an hour left
you should be able to be like i can have
any drug i want because yeah it's like a
prisoner's last meal before execution
they just give you a list which is like
acid psilocybin dmt mescaline it's like
yeah man and you decide like weeks
before like hey if the moment comes yeah
and then i turn the light green by like
uh yeah or i'm able to do you could do
it like an ice cream shop you could be
like can i do half dmt half psilocybin
they would be like yeah buddy yeah it's
yours
it's your special day party
and they monitor your heart rate yep
monitor your brain waves or whatever and
they're like well you someone's like
give me the full blast of all of you
know of acid dmt and celestia give me
the joe rogan treatment that's what
they've called it
i saw
a broken punch alexandria cortez uh
tweeted out last week that she had
somehow included in the ndaa
uh something about legalizing psilocybin
and mdma for pape for people to like
patients and stuff yeah and i got mixed
with you really do that yeah it's on
twitter at least last week i think that
is very healthy you know more and more
popular i mean look man these
politicians the second they see money is
behind it you know tim ferriss a lot of
guys like that in sort of like the tech
self-help podcast world have done a
great job about talking about psilocybin
for ptsd for depression for all this
stuff and there's a new
michael pollan has been great there's a
new documentary on netflix that comes
out this month all about the medicinal
uses of psilocybin by michael pollan who
his book is called i think it was the
number one bestseller how to change your
mind was his book all about um
psychedelics and there is going to be a
real movement for
once politicians see that there is money
behind it we saw it with weed
legalization suddenly they're all gonna
be little jerry garcias and they're all
gonna be like yeah man like i'm totally
for it yeah i think the fear of
psychedelics is that it can make people
so radical that they'll flip the system
on its head
but the system is breaking so hard right
now that we need to shake it and people
will see there is money involved we can
fix our economy with with creativity i
got an idea for like a short film yeah
where it's like a dude who does dmt and
they say you blast off right
you like perceive another dimension or
something but you're still tethered to
your body so you like come out of your
body into the dimension but then you
snap back once it wears off right but
then eventually when he's blasting off
he's like
something happens as an earthquake or
whatever and like his house falls down
and he dies
separating himself from his body and now
he's trapped in like the machine elf
world because there's no way to go back
because normally when you die like your
body is there and it doesn't go there
but now you're here and then when you're
trapped yeah so the way the spirit
detaches from the body because of the
dmt infusion it's spinning
maybe differently than the than a spirit
that is detached without the dmt you
know like what is a spirit we think of
it as like a magnetic i think that
sometimes magnetic field but there's
more to it it's like gets smaller than
that you see these spinners these
sub-atomic billions and trillions of
spinning
black protons around black holes and
things and like why are they spinning
that way that could be altered or at
least that'd be a function i volunteered
to i'll do it let's let's make some
films maybe some short films yeah we'll
get to it uh but we'll read your super
chats for now let's go if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends if you like
it and head over to timcast.com and
become a member why
we're going to be launching a bunch of
shows behind the paywall oh man i hate
saying behind people like we're going to
be doing basically what every other
service does 10 bucks a month you get to
watch all the shows we make we're going
to make a bunch of shows we got tales
from the inverted world we've got uh tim
cass uncensored after our show we're
gonna have that episode
of this show uncensored conversation
going up at about 11 p.m tonight and
we're launching other shows we've got a
couple comedy specials we're preparing
get excited we've got uh documentaries
we're preparing a lot of work's going to
happen and maybe within the next few
months we'll slowly start rolling out
more and more and upping the quality but
the most important thing
when you sign up at timcast.com we are
now using parallel economy
uh dan bongino is on their front page i
think he's like their spokesperson or
involved i'm not entirely sure his
position but this is an alternative
censorship resistant platform so
if you like we got rid of paypal paypal
is no longer on the site if you are a
member and you use paypal nothing will
change
there is no simple way um i'm not
entirely sure what what happens i think
for some people
if you are using paypal
it might start slowly just flipping you
to parallel economy automatically like
the next month or something i'm not
entirely sure
i don't know if canceling and resetting
up is the right thing to do because it
might just end up charging you again so
then like if you're like 10 days into a
month you'll get charged another 10
bucks right away i don't know if you
know specifically or anything yeah this
is actually a question i just got i said
i'm not sure who i used to subscribe but
i assume i'll get an email if i need to
do something to keep my subscription
going
not sure let me tell you our website's
fairly janky yeah
worse comes to worse you gave one time
you gave us 20 bucks yeah the content
you love
yeah if if look i'll put it this way too
so whenever you do a transaction right
paypal takes a cut visa mastercard they
get their card or whatever when you sign
up with parallel economy parallel
economy gets a cut you want this awesome
i don't like the idea that having paypal
on the website meant that you guys were
funding paypal nobody likes that right
and so we've been working very very hard
to get this up and running we finally
did it it was going to be last week then
it got delayed there were some errors
now it's up there's probably going to be
some bugs but i'm really excited that
when you sign up for timcast.com the
overwhelming majority of the money goes
to timcast.com and then a tiny portion
for the transaction goes to parallel
economy which is building a payment
system that we can use that won't censor
us for bs reasons because if you go on
twitter you're going to see that paypal
bans people arbitrarily yeah there's
still a risk because the overwhelming
majority of the people who are signed up
use paypal and if paypal gets mad at us
for smack talking them then maybe they
cause serious issues for us so
sign up
use parallel economy and then that's it
baby
the worst worst case scenario youtube
doesn't like what we have to say we use
rumble whatever we'll we're using them
for all of our behind the scenes video
player and stuff and we're using
parallel economy for memberships it's
going to come to a point where we're
going to have
this entire streaming platform with
numerous shows with a massive staff of
thousands of people bigger than disney
and we will be setting will be setting
the cycle we'll be telling these big
companies they can't control us yep
let's read your super chats smash that
like button let's see what you got
otherwise i'll just keep ranting about
why i'm so excited about parallel
comments
all right smoothie card says tim my wife
and i started a business called smoothie
cards to teach people about nutrition
and we're selling them on amazon now
it's been lots of fun seeing you guys
get on the health train keep it the good
work i look that up absolutely healthy
nutrition is so important especially for
mental health nutrition and working out
and somehow the left became the party of
like during covid like we're against
going outdoors and working out and it
drove so many of my jiu-jitsu friends
away from it it is huge i was depressed
this weekend i made myself eat healthy
and work out and i was better that's
right very much helps all right 3qh says
hey tim i agree we have to make a
culture to win the culture war my maga
band drops red-pilled music here and i
started a show at red pill fight club
very very cool
mirik schlong says tim can you bring mtg
back on and ask her why she voted
against expanding va benefits for gwot
vets
who were affected by burn pits please i
support her but the issue affects me
directly and i want to know the details
behind it i gotta no i gotta be honest
she's gonna have a reason i guarantee
you
when you when when you look at
like look we can talk about her tweets
and her facebook posts and roll her eyes
but what wind up show like thomas massey
had this right he voted he voted no on
something he's like the only one and
everyone's like whoa wait a minute and
then he immediately comes out on twitter
and is like this is exactly what
happened and you go oh you go like here
was the other thing that they inserted
in the bill that has nothing to do with
the bill
ricardo santos says tim have a legal man
from the quash podcast he's a lawyer
destroying the illusion of
constitutional republic and promoting
decentralized systems i like the idea i
like the idea
redco says drink a shot for every
mention of civil war trump and cult i
said civil war once just now when i read
that and twice just now when i said it
again referencing that i that i said it
a few times
so twice yeah
and um we said cult several times yeah
yeah
today was a big cold show but that was
that was because that was because of my
past so i take the blame
jamie will take all the shots
there we go i'm very drunk no
i have not drank at all
all right
steve south how can existing tim kiss
members switch from paypal to parallel
economy do we have to cancel and sign up
again
um so for those that didn't hear it i
did just mention it
no
i don't think so
let give me let me circle back with the
team i'll circle back
and we'll figure out i think
next month it might automatically just
transport you over i'm not sure
if not and you just want to support us
and make sure
you can cancel and re-sign up or
something that might not be a good idea
i don't know it might be burdensome on
our end but i'm not entirely sure it may
be cool it would probably end up giving
us a little bit extra money because you
you know so let me let me circle back to
make sure because i don't want people to
have to spend extra money for something
they've already paid for
tim jake says i worked the dod space
mission for 27 years the level of
ignorance your friday guest displayed
concerning how things operate in space
was absolutely mind-numbing that's alex
uh he was trolling you guys he's he said
at the beginning in the middle of the
episode he loves andy kaufman he said i
don't trust the government and then he
immediately started saying but barack
obama said it was real so just rewatch
it and thinking maybe he's trolling yeah
he might be trolling you he's a
brilliant genius andy kaufman's a genius
yeah too he might have been trolling you
but yeah it was still fun anyway to have
like a moon landing oh so good we never
get to debate that i would love to
actually debate joe on that because i
don't know if he's still like wasn't he
like a big moon landing denier i believe
there was a phase i think he went back
on it but i'm not sure and they get it's
alex stein in case you're wondering what
we're talking about look at the alex
stein episode from france i just want to
like say like when people are like you
can't go through the van allen radiation
belt it's like
you can just you know if they don't care
about you you can jump through the fire
yeah like
yo
the government doesn't care about you
like oh yeah they test on it right if
they wanted to go to the moon they'd be
like sure it's safe no problem yeah but
now that put some poor people in that
shuttle first i'm sure astronauts sign
like whatever happens happens they said
they were seeing stars and sparkles in
their eyes that's when radiation is
bombarding your optic nerve
so it's like oh boy that's bad news
yeah yeah i read about that and i was
reading some conspiracy about it and
then i read that statement where they
were like it was it was amazing seeing
like the flashes and i was like
i think you guys are getting blasted man
you guys ever see stars
mm-hmm yeah i could hit tv one time yeah
oh no they're they're stars those good
stars no no i mean like get hit in the
head or just see like a bunch of stars
yeah yeah like on a cartoon once yeah
it was like a cartoon all right steve
bourdame says hey 10 these documentaries
you keep talking about will you have
them on blu-ray or dvd on your website
when you're done also i would do
mushrooms with a graphene group anytime
i know he'll keep the spiders away i
don't think we have a plan for like
blu-ray dvd i mean maybe we'll put him
up on amazon or something but they're
very preliminary right now we've got
some work being done on a federal
reserve documentary talking about
like how it started what it currently
does and what proposed solutions to the
problems are i'm excited for that it'll
probably on the website i'm very excited
also if psilocybin is involved i would
advise fasting i'm not a shaman but just
uh i would advise set and setting
um
which is you know don't go do it and go
to like hooters um i i would be
introspective about it i would do it
with someone who knows what they were
doing i would put on good music i would
be out in nature somewhere safe i would
not be in a car or anything like that
triton54 says taylor cast castle has
been on point the past two episodes glad
to see you found a home at tim cast
great to see your creativity on screen
the vlog is really top-notch long live
chicken ian thanks for your support i
have a lot of fun filming for the vlog
i'm excited that we're going to have a
little bit more freedom to say whatever
we want to and now that it's going to be
on tim castle.com oh
well i guess that the announcements are
already been made
i thought you already were no
oh no let's let's run with this so
what's happening wait did i just
spill the beans
did i just like i said
i'm sorry oh my gosh i love it i was mad
at you for getting all the credit for
the vlog and that person didn't even
mention me
okay to be fair someone told me earlier
that you mentioned it in a segment
earlier today i i didn't realize that
telephone where i made weekends
so what's happening i'm sorry um we are
going to be
well you know
i'll i'll keep it simple because we have
an episode like we have a full
experience tune in tomorrow
youtube.com
but we're basically
increasing production increasing quality
but reducing frequency
and uh
simple version is we're gonna try and
like scale this up for a weekly a weekly
sitcom slash vlog kind of like it is but
the concern we've had is that it's a
little rough around the edges people
have really liked the way the directions
been going but it's kind of like we know
it's a bit amateurish so we were like
well maybe we should stop trying to
treat it like a like a mix between what
what youtube was with jake paul and what
30 rock was and just go for it as a
weekly
but try and
we'll have like real elements that are
fun like when we taylor and i played
skate it was just us hanging out it was
kind of fun and funny people no that was
fake when he beat me in skate
sage that yeah sure
every game but yeah i think making it a
show i feel incredibly embarrassed for
telling the news i didn't realize tip of
the spear
no we're gonna we're gonna run with it
and we're gonna use it uh to promote
which is the the comments we've gotten
have been so cool because what we were
trying was something
super weird and different and
the the the hardcore fans who write me
on twitter about it every day who
reference the you know literally i've
had people in the street come up to me
and be like guns like because of me and
tim's one bit about it that's exactly
the kind of community we want to build
and by putting it by making it on our
own terms and not youtubes we just get
to make it edgier and we get to talk
about whatever we want
we wrote some really funny jokes we
can't do on youtube no and they're not
offensive jokes they're like vaccine
yeah and like that kind of conversations
are like trump and it's like okay
youtube won't allow that or if they if
if we do it they'll flag us they'll
knock us down i've already ridden a
vaccine and hunter biden joking to the
pilot i know and it's like and i'm so
excited it's gonna be
like obviously we still want to avoid
swearing we want like the like the the
jokes we had that youtube won't allow
they're not raunchy and they're not
they're not like hate speech or anything
like that like they don't offend like
they don't offend anybody but youtube's
delicate sensibilities in the world
health organization and the democrats
and it's just stupid but the you the
channel will still exist but it will
i'll tell you another thing that
happened we did a chicken ian cartoon
and it gets like 60 000 views and i'm
like it's because a singular bit is easy
to share and it's fun to watch
and so we need to have those who want to
watch a full show who want to you know
pay to watch a full show support it
because otherwise it's too expensive and
then we want to do bits that do better
on the youtube channel to be shared yes
so i i don't want to get too much more
into it
it's all exciting it'll the full explain
explainer where we're all talking about
it is up tomorrow at
youtube.comcastcastle
right and um oops but back to that
comment i i do feel very welcome here
and i'm grateful to be here and
i i feel like i got lucky having been
cancelled and it all worked out for me
yeah there you go i couldn't have ended
up any place better honestly it's really
communication is key yes the beginning
of great great things all right let's
see
uh
jerk off juggernaut says i tried to make
a point between lauren southern and milo
and youtube didn't want it and i said
nothing bad just watch her latest video
oh i saw a part of that did you guys
know what's her video she did like a
three hour expose on her experience
being on the right and about it's not
all
unicorns and rainbows like people are
dirty in every area you go and let me
tell you my experience dude every time i
go to a new place so far this has been
fine over here but i remember you know
like i dropped out of high school and i
was like everyone's so mean and then my
first retail job was with a bunch of
like
housewives and i'm like oh they're doing
the same stuff and then i was like okay
comedy they're a bunch of artists and
i'm like no they're gossipy monsters too
and then i'm like i'll go back to music
and it's like the bottom line is you
just have to be as good of a person as
possible and be true to yourself and
find your tribe and find your people
because man there are trash monsters in
every facet of life and you just gotta
find the good ones
all right kevin d says the tweet is
hilarious what are you guys talking
about the left has lost its mind time to
start treating them as such mtg ftw
that tweet no look look
like i said a lot of people are going to
absolutely love mtg's tweet i'll tell
you my perspective
i'm reading the tweet again i
i try to de-escalate right yep and so
when i see tweets like that or i see
like alex stein my initial reaction is
like let's try and yes simmer things
down
but i also feel like
i don't know if that matters anymore
it matters it's it matters that we push
the envelope and that we acknowledge
when we do
maybe well i also think like you can't
study you can't you can't give up
because i think that's the reason you
have reasonable people who tweet me and
the audience you have is because you can
admit when something is funny you can
admit when something's extreme like you
not being beholden to that i think is a
good thing
yeah i actually when we had alex stein
on a friday because he had said big
booty latina aoc and i was like yeah
like what
what right does she really even have to
be upset with someone
like or i was like people really
shouldn't be harassing our senators on
the steps of the of the building and he
was like actually yeah they yeah they
should or whatever he whatever happened
he defended they should be confronting i
was like she shouldn't have the right to
like yell out hey be upset about that
he's like yeah she should have the right
to do that and be upset with what i did
actually yeah that's all right the one
free man says chase bank canceled my
accounts without warning not frozen wife
stranded 120 miles away no food or gas
couldn't pay employees over a week to
fix no access to hundreds of thousands
whoa
the livelihoods of over 20 people still
no answer or reason weird scary social
credit score future oh my gosh it's it's
coming
parallel economy
parallel economy yes
all right
eric wallen says the height study needs
a follow-up lefties scored low in purity
as well but if you live through the
pandemic you saw a massive authoritarian
purity signal from the left
yeah
that would be interesting i don't know
how you'd you'd track for that but that
would be interesting
all right courtesy says with enough
faith we can walk through the fire
completely unscathed just like
shadrach meshach
oh who's that those are the guys in the
story of daniel and they talk about how
they went into the fire and god saved
them and the king looked the king who
threw them into the fire looked in and
saw them just standing there praising
god it was really nice did homie and the
bible get me tood as well i know right
apparently
yeah all right and the lord saith this
me too is bs
i'm correct
jezebel.com
it's actually in there it's like no
one's ever read this page
yeah
michael calderon says shout out to the
irl billboard on hallston chicago avenue
and he thought of making a spanish
version or dubbed version of your shows
wait wait hold on it's still there oh i
don't know well you know like sometimes
i put up billboards and then never take
them down yeah i wonder if they took
that too it just became a forever
billboard
i love it what the the the company is
really trying to get us to times square
stuff again and i want to
but yo
it's expensive
like we got a deal i guess because like
it was like it was like the end of covid
and so the the deal we got was like okay
yeah we could do this
and now it's like here's the next one
and i'm like
no way if we have something to promote
well i mean we can always promote this
show but we got to figure out we're
doing ads on facebook and instagram
right now
i was gonna and i think i just submitted
i've been trying to get ads on spotify
forever but spotify has rejected every
single one for some reason that's weird
the first it was like you're not allowed
to promote other platforms and i was
like oh okay
then so i i changed it uh and changed
the audio and they were like you're not
allowed to promote other platforms and i
was like what my website i can't do an
ad for a web okay so i took it out and
then there's like the picture had
something in it and it's like you're
like bro we're getting so many letters
about rogan can you just let us just
take a break it's just crazy it's like
i'm gonna pay you to promote your
platform i guess right right
whatever they're so gross
but um i want to do reddit ads too but
reddit's really weird and confusing we
should do rumble ads
yeah
yeah but
to get people to go to the west front
top front and center on rumble for like
a week or two weeks or something yeah
we'll see what happens
all right david a says do not try and
walk through the fire that's impossible
instead only try to realize the truth
there is no fire then you'll see that
it's not the fire that burns only your
enemy whoa wow
that's the matrix interesting i don't
remember that it's been a long time
you can't bend the spoon that's
impossible instead you have to realize
the truth
there is
all right uh ona comey says have you
seen tom finn's twitter post about
congress pushing new marriage
legislation including group marriages or
any kind of marriage legalized by any
state
any kind huh
like sister wife stuff
interesting so sister wives what is it
like when someone has multiple wives oh
okay
so
she means uh sexy what's the word she
was looking for
sister wives huh
all right
what do we got here
de bronx says can people who advocate
for sex changes of children still
complain about clitorectomy among young
girls in muslim countries
wow i've never heard that i mean the
oroville
did an episode this season about
de-transitioning a kid
and the bad guy was the one who wanted
the kid transitioned it was kind of like
i think they were trying to play it both
ways somehow but like the gist of the
story is
they transitioned to baby because that
was normal in their culture
and then when the kid grew up and said
this is not right i don't want to be
this way they reversed it but the the
tradition on the planet was to trans
your kids so they were like your
backwards trent your traditions you need
to abandon them and i was like
seth macfarlane basically made the
traditionalists the one who want to
transgender their kids it was like it
was weird wild yeah it was wild
yep
and i i don't i don't know i like
it certainly was not woke
i wish i could understand the way his
mind works for
seven seconds or something yeah in the
end
it's a little girl who is transitioned
to be a boy and then doesn't want it and
like this doesn't feel right and then
they were like no you can't do it and
they have to violate regulations to undo
the surgery or whatever it's like
and then they do and then the uh
traditionalist
the alien race they're all male so
that's why they force trans their kids
so the ones like this is wrong and he
leaves and then he's like why can't you
give up your backwards transition
traditions or whatever seth macfarlane's
like let's take an idea now that idea is
a hammer and here's another idea this
idea is a nail now the whole room's on
fire yeah and you're like what's
happening
in all seriousness though the stories of
d transitioners are really tragic and
then a lot of times they don't get much
support they get banned negative support
yeah
all right frankie perez says tim my wife
and i love your show it would be wicked
to have isaac butterfield on the show
he's an australian youtube commentator
on society that would be fun to watch on
this platform oh is he stateside
i don't know looking about otherwise i
don't know how you get them out there
yeah it's hard to the united states yeah
all right let's see what we got here
let's grab the super chat
david c cronk senior says i never hear
ian call islam a cult
islam is a cult there he is
there he is
as are all religions
judo eagles as a christian couple
doesn't guarantee a christian child of
course so what happened to that
christian couple they did not transfer
their values to their children
well typically what i've seen happen
with christianity is that kids who are
born into it tend to gravitate away from
it but then if their parents taught them
critical thinking and reasoning
they come around to some form of faith
that's exactly what happened with me and
a lot of my peers we weren't just
christian we were raised homeschooled as
well so we had like a serious layer of
what we felt was bigotry for a long time
and then we came back around but um
jewish couples
like religious jews tend to have their
kids adopt their religious values don't
they like i don't know that a tendency
yeah i'm not sure yeah i mean i think in
some cases i was the first generation of
my family to be raised pretty much
secular but i think that a lot of the
values
just like cultural ones and coming from
my parents grandparents probably passed
down to me anyways even though i wasn't
involved in religious stuff yeah i think
you meet a lot more
secular jews or just sort of la we're
all just kind of chill about it and so
there's less there's a lot of religious
juice too no no and on different levels
but like for me jews are really diverse
in that way um i grew up in sort of just
like you know
east coast um artsy middle class
whatever we were
a lot of the jews that i knew most the
jews i knew were
so relaxed about it that the kids just
sort of liked it and didn't want to
rebel whereas i think a lot of you know
christianity it's like very heavy-handed
like you were going to religious school
like right away and so it makes more
sense that you would rebel against that
and i think just the same as like kids
who are raised really religious kind of
venturing out of that and whether they
come back to it or not there are kids
who aren't raised religious who end up
becoming really interested in religion
as they get older right they're curious
they can go both ways yeah and
everything in between
all right john galt says tim pretty sure
prager's model was cut flower morality
morality cut off from the biblical
principles and god will eventually
wither and die
uh and i agree with that because i think
that's what we're starting to see i
think we're seeing
a generation raised without any access
to that information at all and all of a
sudden they're narcissists they're eat
they're com they're completely ego
driven
and i wonder about it i do i mean
for me i grew up in chicago completely
urban secular atheist liberal but
first you know i don't know 10 years of
my life we were catholic
and then we stopped and then i went to
public school and saw a whole other
world and a whole other you know view
but i did learn all those lessons early
in life about morality and why yeah and
i think that i don't want to misrep
represent dennis brigger because i
really like him and i love his uh bible
that he wrote um the version of the
bible that he wrote um he calls it cut
flower ethics i was calling it cut
flower culture because that's the first
thing that comes up when you google it
but i want to say that i feel like the
flaw in
cut flower ethics is that it seems to be
working for a little while and you're
like this is fine this is working and
then you get to where we are now and
you're like this is not working anymore
this is dying unfortunately is that what
it gets to you when people hold up the
idea rather than embody the idea well
it's when you disconnect it from its
roots so you tend to rule out some of
the structure that's underlying it and
it's very dangerous because like like
dennis says it appears to work for a
little while but ultimately it ends up
failing wilting dying as sad
somebody said
where is it i just saw it um
valdo follows his tim your times square
ad is on a netflix resident evil tick
tock with over three point five million
views yeah let's go ahead and
advertising how do we find things let's
go
link link so that's that's the reality
of time square advertising and why it's
so effective and why everybody wants it
because we've had like verified blue
checks with like 100k followers be like
yo i'm in times square and then right
there big and bold on the picture is
like our ad and that's why you do it so
it's very very effective yes so we'll
take a look at that
uh raymond g maga stanley jr the third
says shout out the third shout out to
taylor welcome we are uh of the good
thank you so
uh we are really excited for the vlog
stuff we we've had a bunch of really
funny jokes
we've you know pushed the envelope
obviously we did the one where sheamus
got the cake the coming out cake and we
were like it's edgy it's a little on the
edge you know but we're probably fine
and we've had other jokes like i
mentioned the easiest way to explain it
is like
trump stuff or vaccine stuff where it's
like okay youtube would never allow that
even as a joke they wouldn't care about
the context family-friendly not
offensive doesn't matter so we're really
excited what we're gonna be able to
launch with this show we're there's more
information coming tomorrow but i'll say
this we're thinking it's gonna be like
tuesdays at 7 pm on the website
and we're going to have it as a routine
ready to go we're going to do promotions
for it and then um maybe we were even
talking about maybe doing like a post or
pre-show with like some of the cast
members like or a watch along for some
of them
big promotional stuff so all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.com be a member because when you
sign up now parallel economy is the
principal way we become members that is
rumble's involved it's a company that is
anti-censorship that means for all of us
i don't know if parallel economy is
public-facing yet you can apply to use
their service but once they become like
like paypal you sign up you create an
account
then paypal loses their power then these
woke cults lose their financial control
of things this is what we need to
support so i hit them up
a long time ago like guys what do we got
to do because you know for one we don't
want to get banned for two we want to
support what you're doing so when you
sign up stop giving your money to people
who hate you signing up at timcast.com
uses the rumble player which supports
rumble goes through parallel economy
which supports parallel economy and
supports tim cast to create the content
we love you all so much for doing it
thank you taylor you want to shout
anything out um if you'd like to follow
me on my social media i'm on twitter at
tm silverman and instagram at taylormade
silverman
and thanks for having me on for the
first time it's right out cool to be
here i'm gonna i'm gonna promote the
website i'm going to promote timcast.com
because we're going to do awesome stuff
with the vlog and i know there are
people out here
who for a long time had
no interest in signing up and they were
lying and going well man if they didn't
have paypal you know i just don't want
to support paypal that's the only reason
and now you have no excuse so now you
have to put up or shut up and go to
timcast.com uh follow me on social media
uh i've legitimately you guys have made
me like social media you can follow me
on twitter at jamiekillstein and my
instagram doesn't get nearly as much
love as my twitter which is at the
jamiekillstein and then if you happen to
be in houston i will be doing standup
comedy in two weeks on august 5th and
6th at the riot comedy club um which is
the riot htx dot com you can come say
hey i'm watching me do an hour of filthy
stand up awesome you guys can follow me
in crossland.net if you want to get in
touch with me on social media you'll
find any of my channels through that
portal ian crossland.net very fun you
guys great to have you taylor
do you find you found it so well i did i
found it how do i find it i've i sent it
to you i found the tick tock thing with
our uh with our billboard in it it's a
very cool ad for resident evil and it's
filmed in times square and right up
there in that left-hand corner it's
calm and it has like almost a million
views between the two videos that i'm
looking at right now but you can't
really see the ad you can't so but you
can see part of it and it's pretty big
on tick tock seven hundred and twelve
point six thousand on one and a hundred
that's a cool five thousand that's a
very cool ad so you guys should check it
out if you have tick tock if you've been
compromised by the chinese i am sour
press woods you guys can follow me on
twitterminds.com at sourpatchlist as
sour patch lids dot me i think we got
lucky because when i was talking to the
agency they said the billboard we're on
has been bought for like the rest of the
year
as well as wow yeah like so normally
this is what companies do they'll be
like i want it for the whole year and
they spend like 10 million some
ridiculous number we got it like super
cheap it was expensive don't get me
wrong but like relatively cheap i was
like wow we can afford that and now
they're coming back with like here's the
numbers for the season and i'm like
but this is like the end of summer like
in fall well what probably happened was
covet hit traffic was down and they were
like buy whatever we'll lower the rates
so you know we'll see what happens
everybody thanks for being members what
does this say uh oh here we go trevor
crump said chicken city was live
streaming in the children's section of
the north bend washington twin peaks
library
much better than drag queen's story oh
my gosh that's awesome
right on so i'll just give a shout out
to all the people who work in schools
teachers whatever libraries community
centers if you need something to turn on
turn on chicken city man chicken city
live.com there's funny family-friendly
cartoons that they get tremendous
viewership we're working on another one
it's really really funny and uh thank
you all so much for for watching chicken
city and cass castle and tasting the
invented world we got more coming we
will see you all over at timcast.com for
the uncensored after hours show at about
11 thanks for hanging out thanks
you